In about mid 2018
was when I really decided I was a hundred
percent all in on my centenarian decathlon,
not just sort of in name,
but the sort of the ethos of this thing,
which is I am no longer making any concessions.
I'm really looking forward
to kinda spending the rest of my life,
trying to figure out how to be a healthy,
productive kick ass 90 year old.
(swoosh)
Aerobic base, anaerobic peak, stability, strength.
How do those things matter when you're 90?
And for me, that is the sort of defining principle
of health span is sort of understanding cognitively,
physically and emotionally what you want
in the last decade of your life.
Longevity and health span
are recurring themes on this podcast.
How can we live longer, live stronger?
How can we be more agile, more cognitively fit,
and simply better than previously thought possible.
If like me,
these fields peak your interest,
than you are in for a treat
because this terrain is the absolute obsession
of today's guest, Dr. Peter Attia.
By way of background,
Peter is a graduate of Stanford School of Medicine,
and subsequently trained for five years
at the Johns Hopkins Hospital in general surgery,
where he was the recipient of several prestigious awards.
He also spent two years at NIH as a surgical oncology fellow
at the National Cancer Institute,
where his research focused
on immune based therapies for melanoma.
And currently Peter, in addition to his medical practice,
hosts "The Drive" podcast,
which dives deep into all facets of longevity, health,
performance, wellbeing.
It's absolutely fantastic.
I rarely miss an episode
and highly recommend you check it out.
Peter is incredibly smart.
He's truly innovative in his practice.
He's a relentless self experimenter.
And on top of all of this,
he's also an accomplished endurance athlete.
He's among the very few who have swam
the Catalina channel in both directions
and is also the first person
to double cross the Maui channel,
which is a 28.3 kilometer swim
from Maui to Lanai and back.
In other words,
this is a guy after my own heart.
In today's conversation,
the first in what I hope to be many,
focuses on a few very specific topics,
zone two training, the applied science of longevity,
why we should all be training for what Peter calls,
the Centenarian decathlon and metabolic health,
all things metabolic health.
Peter is a fascinating human.
And this episode is a highly educational treasure trove
of practical actionable takeaways,
certain to improve your current and future wellbeing.
I hope you enjoy it.
So without further ado,
please hit that subscribe button and enjoy.
What years were you at Stanford?
'85 to '89.
You were a Flyer?
I was 200 butterflyer.
And it was a dream come true to be on that team.
Pablo Morales, Jeff Castoff, Anthony Moss.
Pablo and Anthony being number one
and number two in the world at the time, Jay Mortenson.
It was an incredible unbeatable lineup.
Yeah.
And just to be training in like Pablo's lane,
like chasing his feet was like,
I can't even believe I'm here, but not the ideal regimen,
for me to reach my potential, I think.
And Skip is a complicated character.
So I've spoke about it at length on the show, yeah.
My favorite coach is Jon Urbanchek from Michigan.
I don't know if you've ever met him.
I did, I got to,
so Ed Moses was a friend of mine.
I know Ed, I grew up,
we were on the same club team in D.C.
Oh, no, way!
Yeah, he's so much younger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So in 2012,
when ed was trying to come back to make the Olympic team,
we'd become friends 'cause we met at Masters.
Right.
And once I started transitioning
from like ultra distance to pool,
I realized the only thing I could swim was butterfly.
So basically it was like,
I'm gonna swim butterfly in I.M.
That's unusual.
Usually that's the thing people can't do.
Yeah, and it's totally random.
It was like,
'cause I used to swim masters
and all I would do is swim freestyle freestyle.
When they were doing I.M. I was just swimming freestyle.
And then one day I was like,
for reasons we could talk about,
I just decided I'm not gonna swim ultra distance anymore.
I was like, well might as well start doing
all the stuff that they do.
And all of a sudden, like we're swimming breaststroke
and it's like,
I'm swimming as fast as all the lane one kids.
Wow.
And then the coach was like, dude do that again.
And he was like, oh yeah, this is your stroke.
This is what you should have been doing all along.
It's just kind of, it's like,
it's all about the length of your femur,
the flexibility of your hips.
Like it's just, it's a weird stroke.
That was the one stroke
that I couldn't and still can't do.
I don't think you make breaststrokers,
I think you're born a breaststroker or you're not.
Yeah.
So I also grew up with Mike Barrowman
who went on to Olympic glory in the breaststroke
and was part of revolutionizing stroke mechanics.
Yeah.
At the time.
I used to watch the videos
Yeah.
It was incredible.
And his coach József Szabó.
Oh, I didn't know.
Yeah.
Who was a Hungarian guy who really pioneered
like the new way of swimming breaststroke.
And we were just watching the world championships
the other day here at the studio
that's going on in Budapest right now
and watching the breaststroke.
It's totally transformed, totally different stroke.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the training.
It's unbelievable how different the training
is now compared to my era.
I grew up in a period where it was just all about volume.
Yep.
Two hours in the morning, two hours at night.
I mean my high,
I wanna talk about your insane high school regimen
because I had my version of that.
All in the water.
I'm gonna out work everybody.
Yeah.
Yeah, all in the water.
And I learned kind of early and often,
that I wasn't the most talented kid,
but I could bridge that gap by just outworking everybody.
So I was the most reliable person
to show up for morning workout.
The coach gave me the key 'cause
I was more likely to show up than him even.
And I was successful in that regard,
but it required just an unbelievable
amount of volume and work.
And now when I look at the times,
especially world records
that are being broken by like 17 year olds,
I'm like, how is this possible?
The times are so much faster than anything I could have
possibly even conceived of in that time.
And my only sense of how that's possible
is huge strides in training methodology.
For sure.
And I got a taste of that.
I've dropped in from time to time at USC
and trained with the postgrad kind of Olympic crew there,
like Ryan Lochte and guys like that.
Yep.
And I didn't even know what was going on.
Well, Urbanchek was coaching on the days
that I went 'cause I wanted to go see him.
I think Dave Marsh was there as well.
Yep.
And I didn't even know what was happening.
It was all about power off the wall.
Yep.
Speed, explosive speed.
Like we were just doing wall work the entire time
and putting like mesh bags around our feet.
And I was like.
Just dragging parachutes.
I can't do any of it.
What happened to like 20 times 200,
stuff that I used to do.
Well, to your question about how I met Urbanchek,
so I just like kind of lopped onto Ed's feet and I was like,
hey dude, can I come to whatever practices you're doing?
And he's like, yeah, sure.
It's like me and four other professional swimmers.
And I was like, great.
And John was like, yeah, cool.
So they would do two a days
and I would watch morning practice, film, study,
and then I would join the afternoon practice in my own lane
and yeah, look, it was lots of 75's,
lots of 50's from the middle of the pool.
Hmm.
Right, right, so.
50 reps from the center of the pool,
dead stop, go, boom, back.
So.
Right.
And then sort of,
I became just so obsessed with that,
that I kind of brought that back
to our master's program and I was like, look guys,
would you guys be willing to do kind of the workouts?
The best in the world are doing it.
Let's do it one day a week.
Let's pick Sundays and we'll kind of do our own workout.
Right.
They're very hard workouts.
Was that when you were living
in Southern California? Yeah.
Yeah, in San Diego.
So I swim at Mission Valley Y.
Right.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Was not there a spark to like compete Masters then,
once you realized like you were a breaststroker?
Yeah, for about a year and a half, I did and loved it.
Totally loved it.
And then, basically just the cross training
I was doing on the bike
got me a little more excited about being
on the bike and also kind of,
I think part of what was so fun about the Master's program
is what a tight knit group we were and we loved competing.
We went to every single meet
and it was a bit of a hike for me.
We moved further north in San Francisco.
So I moved to a different Master's club
and it was just not,
like nobody wanted to go to meets.
Right.
People were there to exercise, which is fine,
but there wasn't any of that
kind of like we're gonna compete.
And so then swimming for me
just became kind of a back burner thing.
And then that's when I really picked up the bike,
which was about 2012.
Yeah.
When I was living in San Francisco,
I would swim with the USF Masters.
And that was a pretty hardcore group at that time.
I don't know if it still survives to this day.
When I was in the Bay Area,
I'd swim at Stanford until I kind of got,
are we recording?
Yeah, we're on.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got a little bit of trouble at Stanford
and then I switched.
Why is that?
Because Dick Jokoms would come to the practice
to coach me and 'cause he knew
like I wanted to do ultra distance swimming so.
Right.
I'd be at the Stanford Master's practice
and Dick would be standing there giving me instruction
and afterwards, the Stanford Master's coach, understandably,
was like, dude, you can't have Dick standing here.
Right.
And I was like,
alright, well then I'm gonna go swim at Menlo.
It's sort of classic Atilla though.
Like you're gonna do a end
run around whatever the protocol is and figure out.
So in deference and respect to the program,
I went and joined Menlo and they were totally cool.
Right.
And it was a much more mellow program.
Yeah, yeah.
I know some of the people there, that's cool.
But they were like, yeah,
we don't care what you do.
Well, what's interesting is you picked up swimming
later in life.
It's a very difficult thing to do for most people
and then distinguish yourself in some pretty impressive
water performances.
I know that you downplay it and all of that,
but are you not like the only person?
You were the first, right?
I'm sure other people have done it.
The double Maui channel crossing?
Yeah, although I have to be honest with you,
I found out a few years later,
that there might have been somebody
who did it earlier,
but I don't know the details of it, but at the time,
it appeared I was the first to do it.
Yeah.
That's no small feat.
I mean, look, I think you have to put feats
in different categories, right?
I think many more people could have a potential
to do something where the challenge is just,
can you grind it out?
Then the number of people
that have the potential to say,
be the fastest to do something.
I think those are just two different things.
Right.
If you're willing to put in
the unbelievable amount of time
to prepare for something like that,
it's doable essentially, is what you're saying.
Absolutely, it's just about putting your head down
and actually the challenge with the Maui swim,
is I wanted to start at midnight.
So originally my plan was to do something even more
audacious was to go Maui, Lanai, Molokai, Maui,
to swim the triangle, which is a 30 mile circuit.
But there's no way you could do that,
if you didn't start at 10 o'clock at night,
because you can't be out there during the trade winds,
it's just unswimmable and the boat captain,
who's a great captain said,
there's just too many tiger sharks out here.
And when we put a glow stick on your suit,
which we have to be able to do to be able to see you,
you're just gonna be chum.
Yeah.
So he's like,
I can't let you start before 5:30 in the morning.
And that kind of limited how long I could be out there.
So then I said, okay, well, let's do this double,
which was still a great swim, but it.
I mean, there's pretty regular
shark encounters during the Maui channel swim
that they do every year,
that's primarily like a relay race.
Yep.
That they do in conjunction
with the Waikiki open water swim.
I'm constantly hearing,
I have tons of friends who've done it.
It's all fine,
but like it's not without its shark problems.
Yeah, now there's more sharks in the Molokai Channel.
So that channel is really sharky.
And I've got a friend who's done that in both directions
getting, Forrest Nelson.
I mean, that's a tough channel.
That's about 26 miles.
And I mean, there's nothing between you and the ocean.
The water's.
Way out there.
Oh yeah, it's incredibly rough.
It's all about the currents.
Yeah.
With that kind of thing.
I just know from doing the Alcatraz swim,
it's all about timing the start.
And you can be,
you wanna be doing your cross right at the slack.
Yeah.
Between the ebb and the flow
and the longer that you're out there,
the more susceptible you are
to the current kind of going out towards the bridge.
Yeah, yeah.
I've done Alcatraz a few times and it's actually,
I think it's a harder swim,
to swim into aquatic park,
even though it's a shorter swim,
because you're really threading the needle
to get in between those two points.
Right, exactly.
Whereas when you go to what's it called Crissy Field?
Yes.
Yeah, that's a longer swim, but it's easy.
'Cause the current starts
to actually push you in that direction.
Push you in that direction, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you tack straight
and you just naturally gravitate towards
that finish point, interesting.
In addition, a couple Catalina crossings,
but now you don't swim at all.
I don't swim at all 'cause I'm three months
outta shoulder surgery.
So yes, I definitely don't swim at all.
Is that the only reason though?
No, I had stopped swimming,
but I'm gonna get back to it.
I think, I'll never do the, I don't think,
I mean the only condition under
which I would do a marathon again
is if one of my kids wanted to.
When I was in the ocean, last time we were in Hawaii,
I think my son was four and we were,
we were at the sort of Eastern tip, no,
the Western tip
of Maui and you can see Molokai.
Right.
And he was like, what's that?
And I told him and he's like,
he's really interested in that.
And I was like, buddy,
if you ever decide you wanna swim there,
I will come outta retirement and we will do it together.
That could be an incredible bonding experience.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, this is a good kind of way
to segue into one of the main
topics that I want to get into with you,
which is this notion of the Centenarian decathlon.
And I have a very peaked interest in this moment
around all of these ideas
that have become kind of at the forefront
of what you talk about and write about
through my own experience of dealing with lower back pain.
Suddenly, I'm in a position where I can't run without pain.
And even if I'm on the bike for more than a couple hours,
my back becomes intolerable.
I've got an L4 that's kind of out of whack
and sciatic pain.
So I was like, alright, well, I'll swim,
I'll get in the pool.
This should be supportive.
And I signed up for the Key West 20 kilometer swim,
which was just this past weekend,
with the intention of competing in that.
But when the yardage started to stack up
around 6,000 or 7,000
yards per workout, like my back just couldn't deal with it.
And I don't know if that's.
Was that in open water or with flip turns?
Well, it was, yeah, it was flip turns.
So yeah, so I think it was, it's all the turns.
Yeah.
I just couldn't do a flip turn anymore without pain.
And so now I'm sidelined in a way
that I haven't been in the history of my experiences
of being an athlete
and I'm now compelled out of pain
to confront and deal with this
situation in a meaningful way.
And it's been really humbling.
And so as I think I messaged to you like the videos
that you're putting up about mobility
and like glued activation and all of these things,
have been like the most important thing in my life
as I slowly kind of acclimate to a new way
of thinking about fitness through movements, etcetera.
So I think it would be instructive to explain
how this became of interest to you.
And it's obviously, it's part and parcel with your interest
in longevity, but maybe kind of walk us through that.
I mean, there's a story that you probably know,
but I think it might be helpful to just explain
an unfortunate reality of our species,
which is we tend to respond best to pain.
A hundred percent.
I mean, any change I've ever made
is only because I've been forced to out of extreme pain.
Yeah.
So my first brush with that
came in my last year of medical school.
So it's June of 2000 at our Alma mater, right?
So I'm just on my bike riding to the gym
back when it was the Arriaga Center there,
I get off my bike,
getting ready to lock it up and I'm like,
God, something does not feel right in my back,
like a really weird pain.
And so bad in fact that I decided,
you know what?
I'm gonna get back on my bike and ride back
to wherever I live.
I think I lived in Escondido Village or something.
So I do that.
And I'm thinking, you know what, I'm gonna be fine.
I just need to kind of rest today,
which is very unusual for me.
Like I'm not that guy who takes a day off.
Well, the next day I can't actually get out of bed.
So I actually call my roommate, two separate lines.
I'm like, dude, you gotta get me up.
And to make a long story short,
that transitioned into kind of two weeks of debilitating
back pain that ultimately led
to what I didn't realize at the time was a free fragment.
So a fragment of my L5S1 disc broke off,
was about four centimeters long
and it just parked itself on my S1 nerve route.
So now I just had the sensation of skin
being peeled off the bottom of my left foot.
So I kind of sucked this up for a week.
And then finally the Dean of the medical school
saw me limping and he's like, what's going on?
And I told him, and he said, we gotta get you an MRI now.
He took me, got an MRI.
The next morning I was in surgery
and it was just, everything went wrong.
So it was a botched operation.
The guy operated on the wrong side,
I came out with a foot drop on the right leg.
So my right leg.
At Stanford hospital?
Yeah.
Wow.
So my right foot had a drop.
So now I couldn't walk 'cause I'm dragging the right foot.
This turned into an unbelievably complicated story
that I won't bore everybody with,
but the punchline is I needed multiple trips
back to the operating room to fix this problem.
And I was probably three months
of only able to lay on a floor.
Wow.
Or bed, like those are my only two positions.
Mom had to fly down to take care of me,
to feed me, didn't lay down.
Went from I'm not sure I'll be able to be a surgeon,
I'm not sure I'll graduate on time,
to I'm not sure I'll ever walk again.
Wow.
And then an amazing doctor there,
actually a guy who I'd like
to have on my podcast at some point, his name's Sean Mackey,
he's a pain specialist.
He was kind of the guy that broke this cycle
and began the treatments that were,
that got me outta pain enough to then do the rehab.
And amazingly within a year of that incident,
I was at Hopkins standing on my feet, operating,
as a surgical resident.
But that was like kind of an aha moment.
And that's also what led to me getting into swimming.
So three years later when I'm, so that was,
I was 28 when that happened.
So by the age of 31 I decided,
I'm gonna mix things up a little bit
and try this other thing, swimming.
So that experience stuck with me.
And I do think of that as kind of the best,
worst experience of my life,
'cause it gave me a really close up view
of what it means to lose your body.
And I think most people,
unfortunately don't figure that out,
until it's too late to do anything about it.
And I got a second chance, right?
Which is not to say that at that moment I conceived
of what I'm doing today, I certainly didn't.
I would spend the next,
18 years pursuing other performance metrics,
but it's never left my mind and it's now,
completely shaped how I think
about taking care of patients and myself.
What's unique and interesting about you
and the work that you do,
is that you're perhaps the only person in the world
or at least the only person that I can think of,
that has such an in depth level
of expertise in both performance,
athleticism and kind of the mechanisms
behind how to optimize that and longevity,
like how to promote that effectively
through evidence based medicine and science.
And it seems like these two worlds are orthogonal to each
other and you've seem to find a way
to kind of synthesize the best of those.
So how do these two worlds intersect
and maybe that's a way
to kind of segue into your
kind of real interest and fascination and longevity.
I think you're astute to pick up on that, Rich,
not the part of my expertise,
'cause I don't think I actually have much expertise
on the performance side,
but I think you're astute to pick up on the notion
that these are often at odds
and it's for that reason that I get contacted
a lot by professional athletes
and by professional sports teams,
probably at least once a month,
you know, coach of an NBA team or something or performance,
some high end performance entity reaches out
and outside of the physiologic sports
like swimming, running, cycling,
where I think I do actually have a pretty good sense
of the physi, especially cycling.
That's probably the one
that has the least technique and the most pure physiology.
That's probably where I would have the most insight,
but what it takes to be exceptional there
and what it takes to live a really long life,
I wouldn't say they're completely orthogonal,
but they're not.
They're certainly nowhere near colinear.
Hm hm.
So for that reason, I just say, look,
I'm not the guy to help you achieve those goals.
I'm probably the guy to help you when you retire
and you wanna work towards a different goal.
I would assume though,
that in the Venn diagram between those two worlds,
that the intersection has to do
with promoting kind of the longevity
of one's career, right?
There are certain things that you can do
as a professional athlete, chasing greatness.
Absolutely.
That can extend the link.
I'm sure like a lot of the people that reach out to you
are in the kind of twilight of their career.
And it's like, how can I eek out
a couple more years doing this while now
we have to open ourselves up to these other protocols.
That's absolutely correct.
And I think,
I have a friend who works most,
exclusively with kind of NFL guys
and his take is from the day you sign
your first contract after the NFL combine,
after you've shown everybody how fast you can run a 40
and how much you can bench press and all that stuff.
Like you stop caring about those metrics forever.
The only metric now that matters is not getting injured.
That's effectively going to determine
your lifetime earnings.
And so it's not really about how much faster can you get,
it's how much safer can you continue to run fast.
Right.
Even if it means running a little bit less.
So, you're absolutely correct.
And in that sense, look, again,
I don't think I'm particularly insightful
or brilliant on those.
I think my insight is how you combine
all of these things, right?
It's how do you think about aerobic base,
anaerobic peak, stability, strength
and how do those things
matter when you're 90
and what what's the standard
we should hold ourselves to?
What's a realistic aspiration
for someone in their marginal decade,
which is the way we talk about the last decade of your life.
And the way that you kind of construct an architecture
around how to think and approach this,
is by working backwards.
Yeah.
From a perspective of what your values
and your goals are
or what you anticipate you're gonna wanna be able to do
when you're 90 or 80 or 70.
And then working back from there to start doing the things
that will put you in a position
to kind of have that capacity.
Exactly.
We would call it forecasting if you say where you are today.
So if you say, okay, I'm 50 today and when I'm 55,
I want to be able to do this.
That works reasonably well for short term goals,
but for really complicated problems,
it seems easier to reverse engineer them.
And I've borrowed the term backcasting from Annie Duke,
'cause I think it's just a better way
to contrast forecasting and backcasting.
And I just don't see how you can forecast 40 years.
It just becomes too vague.
You have to anchor to what you're talking about
40 years out.
And for me that is the sort of defining principle
of health span, right?
Is sort of understanding cognitively,
physically and emotionally what you want in the last decade
of your life and making sure
that you work backwards from there.
And again, it literally feeds into everything.
Like we'll use an emotional example
'cause people don't think about that.
If your vision of the last decade of your life
is to be surrounded by family
who love you and wanna be around you.
But 40 years earlier, you have no relationships.
Your kids hate you because you're a jerk
and you're working all the time.
There's a disconnect.
Like why do you really think your kids
are gonna be around you in 40 years?
If they don't wanna be around you right now?
Right.
So every one of those things has to have a congruency
that comes back.
Now with the emotional stuff,
it's not as metric driven,
but when it comes to the physical stuff,
it's very metric driven
because we know exactly what these things mean.
If someone lays out an aspiration, you can say,
well, that will require a VO2 of this many mills per minute,
per kilogram.
You have to be able,
your muscles have to be able to consume
this much oxygen per minute.
If you actually tell me that you wanna be able to hike up
that canyon in that many minutes,
if you tell me that you wanna be able to stand up
and do X, Y, and Z, it will require this much strength.
And we know the rate at which those things decline
and therefore we project back.
Right.
So typically somebody's gonna say,
I want to be able to play with my grandkids.
I want to be able to go on a hike.
I want to be able to get up off the ground
or get up off a chair and get up out of bed.
Typical type of stuff.
So how do you think about,
or basically what are the pillars of this?
I know you have buckets in how do you think about this?
What are those?
And then from there,
what are the things that
somebody of my age or just
kind of in the middle age sector of life,
what should we be thinking about
and what are some of the practices
that we should be starting to adopt?
I mean, we would start by being
more specific in the marginal decade.
So the one thing we don't know is when your marginal decade
is going to be.
So I don't, you know, I don't,
I can't tell looking at somebody, is it gonna be 80 to 90?
Is it gonna be 74 to 84?
Is it gonna be 89 to 99?
We don't know when that is.
And that does play a role,
but I think it's worth budgeting for it being later,
because that will force you to hold yourself
to a higher standard,
but we begin with much more specificity.
So I think we have a little over 50 questions
we ask our patients and this is absurdly specific stuff.
And some of it is like things you wouldn't think about,
like do you wanna be able to have sex, right?
Because if the answer is yes,
like there is a certain level of fitness,
mobility and strength that's required to do that.
Do you want to be able to walk up
this many flights of stairs?
Do you want to be able to carry
this many pounds of groceries?
Do you want to be able to place something
of this weight above your head?
Do you want to be able to pick up
a child of this weight from the ground?
And we just sort of force people to go through that exercise
and you check off the things that don't matter to you
and check off the things that do.
And what that does is it turns into basically a consolidated
set of metrics for strength and fitness
and other things that are a bit foreign to people
like scapular control.
Lower leg variability.
A big part of what troubles people
when they get older and it gets mistaken a bit for balance,
but a lot of it has to do with not just balance,
but with lower leg variability and you know,
not being able to kind of feel with your feet very well.
Right.
And so falls as an example,
become an enormous cause of morbidity.
I've quoted the stat many times,
but if you're over 65 and you fall and break your hip,
your 12 month mortality,
meaning the probability you'll be dead
within the next 12 months,
depending on the study is 30% to 40%.
Right.
So just starting from that as a baseline,
like let's try to not fall or in the event that we do fall,
how can we be resilient enough,
so that we don't like suffer that type of consequence?
Yeah.
So there's a whole bunch of things
that you work backwards from there
and you'd be amazed at how many people,
even in their forties and fifties, don't possess,
even though they're strong enough
to meet the metrics of their 90 year old self,
they already show signs of weakness in terms of instability
in their hips, instability in their knees,
horrible patterns of walking,
pelvic tilts that are too far forward.
All of these things that they can sort of muscle
their way through when they're younger,
but it becomes problematic later.
Yeah, I mean, I check every single one
of those boxes and I was listening
to the podcast that you did with Lance Armstrong,
and you were talking about this subject
and he was basically saying, look, look,
I just wanna put on my shoes and go run.
Like, I'm not gonna do any of that stuff.
Like that's a hundred percent me, right?
And I did that until I just ran myself
into the ground and couldn't do it anymore.
And you know, a couple things, I mean, first of all,
for many years it was all about power to wait, right?
Yep.
I'm doing these very specific movements.
I'm swimming, I'm cycling and I'm running.
So I had incredible efficiency with certain muscle groups,
but I wasn't doing any of the kind of gym work
required to be balanced in that regard.
And as a result,
I have certain atrophies and I have like misalignment
in my posture and all sorts of things that,
now I'm realizing are super problematic,
not the least of which is my balance is terrible.
Like if I stand on one foot or I try to put my socks on
things like that, like it's hard.
And that was like a huge revelatory moment for me
to realize there's something terribly awry here.
And now I'm on a certain type of protocol.
Like you tell somebody you have back pain,
like people come outta the woodwork and everybody's got
the person you should talk to,
but you gotta pick a lane, right?
So I'm working with a certain PT at the moment.
And one of the things
that this person is having me do,
is a lot of glute activation work.
And you know, I've only been doing this for like a month,
but initially, like I had zero glute.
I couldn't even,
my brain would signal to that muscle group
and it wouldn't do anything.
Like that's how bad that situation was.
And now I can kind of do these little exercises
that are annoying.
And as somebody who's like,
like yourself, like I want to go out and crush it.
It's very humbling to kind of have to let go of all of that
and focus on these little movements.
And again, not to, rehash this,
but you seeing, me seeing you do this stuff
like on video is like, okay, well,
if Peter's prioritizing this,
like I realize this is important.
And it's given me like permission
to really kind of embrace this,
but it's been interesting.
And I realize like how,
how kind of much work remains
in order for me to really be stable.
Look, it took me
probably three years of backing off,
to then go forward again.
So in about late 2018,
mid 2018 was when I really decided
I was a hundred percent all in on my Centenarian decathlon,
not just sort of in name,
but the sort of the ethos of this thing,
which is I am no longer making any concessions,
'cause one of the dirty little secrets is,
and I love a friend of mine, Kyler Brown,
said this to me, he goes,
athletes are the best cheaters, right?
The more you're a grinder,
the better you are at cheating
your way around bad movement patterns.
And you know, I learned this amazingly with my rotator cuff,
I mean, or not my rotator cuff, sorry, my labrum.
So I tore this labrum growing up boxing,
multiple subluxations,
further exacerbated during my open water swimming days.
I was in a swim race once when I was in full extension
and the guy in front of me kicked down,
took the whole shoulder outta socket.
Wow.
So this thing's been shredded for at least 15 years
and I have managed to fight my way through it
and muscle my way through it by cheating,
basically using my rotator cuff to stabilize
the humoral head, using my traps to stabilize it.
Now I've developed a whole bunch of horrible
patterns around it, but he's like,
yeah, that's what athletes do.
Right.
And so.
The downstream implications of that become cataclysmic.
Yeah, you have to start to unlearn that stuff.
So that's what began for me in 2018.
And you know how it presented actually
was I was getting tennis elbow
and I'm like, it's really odd 'cause I don't play tennis.
So that doesn't seem like a likely injury.
And that that's when I first met a guy
who kind of got me on this path
using something called dynamic neuromuscular stabilization.
And he watched me do pullups he's like,
let me see you do a pull up.
And I was like, dude,
I own this baby, watch.
Did a million pullups for him.
And he's like, yeah, it's horrible.
Like your technique is so bad.
You have no scapular control whatsoever.
You are transmitting so much force into your elbows doing
that because you can't keep your scapula in place.
Another big aha moment,
which actually ties into what you said about the glutes.
There is a fundamental difference
between having a strong muscle
and knowing how to recruit it.
And for me, the aha moment came with my hamstrings.
I have always prided myself
in having just the strongest legs.
Right, I mean.
Cyclists have strong legs.
I deadlift tons of weight.
I do insane amounts of stupid leg curls.
You name it I'll do it.
But when I was placed on the floor in a very simple position
laying on your back, knees bent, feet flat on the floor,
could I, without screwing around in my pelvis,
just pull back with my feet.
A pure hamstring recruitment.
No, could not.
Yeah, I can't do that either.
Yeah, couldn't do it.
And so what that says is it doesn't actually matter
how strong your hamstrings are,
you can't recruit them.
And if you can't recruit them,
your pelvis is tilted forward.
You have to be able to keep those hamstrings recruited,
to keep that pelvis in the right position.
I mean, it took me a year of daily.
I mean just grinding away
at these movements in this practice.
And now it's hard for me to remember
what it was like to not be able
to recruit my hamstring.
So it can, you can unlearn these patterns.
But the irony of it is the more
of an athletic background you have,
the longer it will actually take you
to unlearn 'cause you have more bad stuff.
Those neural pathways are so.
They're so wired.
Yeah.
The good news is you have,
you have the reps on how to do stuff.
So I think it's a wash taking an untrained person
and teaching them versus taking a highly trained person
and teaching them.
Takes about the same amount of time,
but for different reasons.
Yeah.
I mean the athlete knows how to commit to something.
Yep.
And follow through.
But the trick is the light bulb moment, right?
Which is usually triggered by an injury
that forces them to the mat, right?
Yep, exactly.
That's the situation that I'm in.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools
and support, very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say, is The Plant Power Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership,
when you use the promo code "rrhealth" at checkout.
This is life changing stuff,
people, for just a dollar 70 a week.
Literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again that's meals.richrolls.com,
promo code "rrhealth" for $10 off an annual membership.
Alright, let's get back to the show.
So for your Centenarian Olympics,
what are the events that you're working towards?
What are the categories?
For me I think my kids
are the greatest source of joy in my life.
My hope is that my kids have kids
and that we're in proximity to them.
And I just get to do the kind of stuff with them
that I get to do with my kids right now.
So again, it's silly, simple stuff, but again,
I'm fortunate that,
I still have two boys that are young five and eight.
And so I realize to play with them is hard.
Like they play on the floor.
We're building Lego,
we're building tracks, we're pushing trucks,
we're doing that stuff.
And when I look at, for example, my dad, who's 85,
he can't engage with kids like that.
And a big part of it is
my dad's mentally as sharp as a tack.
He can't get on the floor.
So something as simple as can you get on the floor.
Spend 30 minutes without your back breaking and get up.
Now that takes a lot of intro abdominal stability.
You really have to be able to initiate intraabdominal
pressure to maintain that position.
And of course,
getting up requires a whole bunch of coordinated activities.
I have a very lofty aspiration,
which if I get there is great,
which is I'm gonna be able to get up
without using my hands still.
Yeah.
Which I can do now, obviously,
but even if I can just do it on one point of support,
that would be fantastic.
I love archery.
It is such a big part of my life.
And even though now I'm pulling a 75 pound bow,
I think to be able to pull a 50 pound bow,
in my marginal decade would be fantastic.
I love driving race cars.
Now, Paul Newman drove a race car
until probably a year or two before the end of his life.
Hm hm.
And so for me,
that's something that I would love to be able
to continue to do.
And that requires not just the strength
and the coordination and the mental acuity to do it.
You have to be able to tolerate insanely hot temperatures.
It gets so hot inside of a race car
that you have to kind of have
the kind of cardiovascular fitness to tolerate that.
Right.
But having clarity about what those things
are allows you to then backcast
to now and start to build the foundation
for that capability.
Yeah, like we were talking about earlier.
I mean, that's a big part of why I do what you do,
which is I do some of my activity.
Like I rock four or five days a week,
carrying a weighted backpack,
but I always do it at like five or 6:00 p.m.
So in Austin, that's about the hottest time of day.
Right.
So it's a hundred degrees.
Sometimes it's a 105, 106,
and you got a 60 pound pack on your back
and you go walk three miles in the hills,
your ability to tolerate heat.
You go to somebody's barbecue at 11 o'clock when it's 90
and everybody's dying.
You're like, this is nothing.
Right.
Yeah, you can acclimate to that.
Yeah.
You just have to engage with it and confront it.
One of the things that you've talked about quite a bit
is noticing how natural it is for your children
to do all of these movements
that then become so difficult for us
as adults because we've unlearned them.
And our sedentary lifestyles kind of detach us from
our kind of natural blueprint
and ability to do those things.
So how can we,
as most people listening or watching this,
probably have to sit in a chair
for their work and we're sitting in chairs right now.
What are some of the practices
that could be adopted to help keep us
connected to that natural ability
that is kind of innate in our unconscious.
I mean, for me, I've taken a very deliberate
approach to that.
So four or five years ago when I got introduced
to this pattern of movement
called dynamic neuromuscular stable.
Yeah, talk about that.
Super interesting.
Yeah, so it kind of grew out of the Czech school.
So, basically God,
I wish I knew the history better.
I've forgotten a lot of it.
About a hundred years ago,
a Czech neurologist was trying to understand
how kids with cerebral palsy
had such difficult times with movements.
And he basically formulated a hypothesis,
which was during the first couple of years of their life,
they were missing out
on some developmental milestones of movement.
And when they didn't get those patterns,
those neuromuscular patterns weren't developed,
they could never,
they became hosed movement wise.
So he said, well,
if we can identify what those are
by looking at kids that don't have CP,
can we teach them to the older kids with CP?
And the answer turned out to be, yes, you could.
So that became the Prague School and that's what they were
primarily doing and then another guy came along,
I'm blanking on his name.
It might have been Vojta
or Vojta might have been the original guy.
I can't recall.
Who basically said, wait a minute,
this is actually a tool that would be really valuable
for prehab and rehab for adults.
And so that kind of morphed the Prague School
into this field of dynamic
neuromuscular stabilization,
which we abbreviate DNS and it's still based
in the Czech Republic or in Czechoslovakia, I guess,
whatever we call it now.
And having now been connected
to a number of these practitioners,
I have found this to be
one of the most important systems that I've incorporated.
So initially my exposure to it
was basically to fix problems, right?
I had two nagging issues four or five years ago.
One was this elbow issue, which again,
I couldn't understand what was causing it,
until I realized it was inability
to localize my and control my scapula.
And the other was just my right SI joint nagged.
It just had this little nagging pain in my right SI joint.
Certainly didn't ever raise to the level
of lower back pain, no sciatica, nothing like that.
But whenever I deadlifted really, really heavy,
50% of those days,
I would be punished with some right SI joint pain.
And again, these two things seemed
completely unrelated until I got
under the hood of what was going on
with my movement patterns.
And I realized, like every,
whatever I was, 45 year old, I didn't know how to move.
So what started out as kind of rehab
has then just morphed into life movements.
So I do an hour a week in person with a DNS teacher.
So guy named Kyle Brown comes to my house once a week.
We just hammer DNS movements together
and then I'll spend 10
minutes every day doing them on my own.
And that has been kind of life changing.
Now, of course, with my shoulder injury,
Kyler is overseeing the rehab there.
And so we're now incorporating really good shoulder rehab
coupled with the DNS principles
of getting my scapula to relearn how to move.
Because when you have this type
of an injury and you have surgery,
the brain really wants to shut off how this thing works.
So now we're just gonna basically reprogramming it.
Right, so what is an example of a DNS movement.
The first one and the core one.
I'm trying to understand.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, visualize it.
The very first one is something
called learning how to access intra abdominal pressure.
So I think most people who think about breathing,
have a pretty good sense that you
aren't just breathing into your thoracic cavity, right?
A good breath has to have the diaphragm going down.
You have to get into the abdomen.
What DNS does is it really explains to you
how a child is breathing, which is,
if you imagine the waistband of your pants or your shorts,
when a child is breathing, that thing is fully expanding.
So they have purely concentric force in their abdomen
with every breath.
And again, if you look at a really good
power lifter or something,
you'll see the same thing.
I mean the amount of intra abdominal pressure
that they have to generate to be able
to move such heavy loads, is essential.
And so that was literally the very first thing we worked on
is just, can you access pelvic floor pressure?
Can you create enough pressure into your pelvic floor?
Can you maintain it while you breathe?
So that first of all,
it's just hard to do that out of the gate.
And the second thing is you can do it,
but you're not relaxed.
So you're gonna have to be able to do that,
hold it while you can breathe around it.
The next things for me that were very important,
I have a very congenitally narrow C spine.
And if you look at an MRI of my neck,
you wouldn't believe what a disaster it looks like,
even though I've never really had an issue,
but I'm being very preventative about it.
And so one of the other things I'm working on is learning
how to use the deep neck stabilizers.
So these are muscles that ride on the back.
They're inside.
You don't see them.
So they're not these scaling muscles that are in front.
They're the muscles that sit
on the vertebral body sort of deep in my neck.
And it's learning how to use those muscles
to keep my head forward.
So I'm not relying on these muscles here.
And so that's a lot of muscle.
That's a lot of movements where I'm on my back.
Chin is forward using the cue of the eyes looking forward,
which kind of lights up that circuit
and using various pelvic positions,
armed positions and light positions in there.
So it's very subtle and gentle,
but it's more about like,
how do I connect my intention in my mind
to these muscle groups to get them to just activate.
The starting positions are now,
it starts to get very elaborate.
Basically, someone Googles sort of a DNS progression,
you'll see how complicated it will get,
'cause you're basically walking
through the first two years of development.
So the stuff I just described is the fetus basically,
and you start moving into a three month position,
a four month, five month,
six month position where now a child is learning
how to roll.
Well, they roll in a very connected way.
So when they're reaching for something with this arm,
they're completely connected across their oblique sling,
and they're gonna initiate that movement
and down to their foot.
This is the other stuff that was just like,
when I look at videos of me four years ago
and videos of me now,
I just don't know what the hell I was doing before.
Wow.
Like how I was getting away with the nonsense
of being completely disconnected,
scapula's all over the place
and all that sort of stuff.
And here's the other thing,
the best athletes in the world kind of naturally do this.
That's another thing I've learned is that there are
some really exceptional athletes out there
who have never once spent a minute learning DNS.
But when you look at them,
they have somehow managed to preserve
those neuromuscular pathways.
And that is essentially a big part
of what their athletic gift is.
And I would imagine it's pretty good
for injury prevention, right?
If you have the ability to recruit all of these muscle
groups you're inherently more stable
and resistant to a lot of the injuries
that are occurring from those imbalances.
Yeah, and that's why for me,
it's a once a week,
do the lesson once a week, you know, push, push,
how much further can I get in those things?
And then it's part of what we call our dailies.
So for our patients,
we program things called dailies.
Like this is gonna, whether today's a zone two day,
a strength day a rest day, you still have your dailies.
You got your 10 minutes of daily.
So I assume there's practitioners,
trained practitioners who can teach this,
but are there YouTube videos?
Like if somebody's listening to this,
how should they go about researching this or finding?
So, I did a podcast with one
of the probably six or seven most prominent teachers
in the United States, a guy named Michael Rentala.
And we have the video of my interview with him.
And then also a few introductory movements,
probably another hour worth of videos we made.
And I suspect there's gotta be a ton on YouTube.
Right.
It's the kind of thing where I hate to say it,
but I do think at least initially,
you do need an instructor
because at least for me,
and I think I have decent proprioception in kinesthetic
awareness, not amazing, but good.
I don't think I could have done it
without somebody there to poke and prod and correct.
And even today, like I just,
I get more out of it when Kyle's there.
And even when he's there,
he's filming me to this day.
Filming and commenting,
so that when I'm doing it on my own,
I'm watching a video and I'm listening to his cue.
And would you say that that is foundational
and a kind of requisite prior to the work
that you do with Beth?
What's her name?
Beth Lewis.
Yeah, Beth Lewis,
who's kind of taking you through some more type of,
kind of movement activation type of exercises.
I don't think there's anybody
who's not gonna benefit from DNS,
but I also acknowledge
that I don't think it fixes every problem.
So there's a whole other system called PRI,
Postural Restoration Institute,
which is amazing at fixing another huge problem,
which is when that pelvic tilts forward, the ribs flare up,
like that's a very common athlete problem.
Beth has names for,
kind of Beth has broken people down
into three phenotypes and I can't remember
what they all are.
There's kind of the Lucy goosey one.
But then there's the like locked and loaded one.
Right.
So that's me, that's Lance, like that's,
our natural state is chest is up, pelvis is forward.
Back is arched.
So excess lordosis and learning how to relax
my ribs has been insane.
Yeah.
The guy who does my tissue work,
who's been working on me for, I don't know,
probably 10 years, eight years,
he's shown me pictures of what my lower back
looked like five years ago.
And I don't recognize it.
So you have these two,
erector spinae muscles that run down your spine.
If you look at my erector spinae five years ago
and you look at them now, you can't believe it.
Like right now, my back is just flat.
Like there is no bulging musculature adjacent to my spine.
And before it was just, that was always on fire.
I had these huge muscles running up my back
that were just holding me in that locked position.
Yeah.
And that's all from being able to just do this.
This is exactly where I'm at right now.
Yeah.
It's so locked up back here.
And when I lie flat and I try to do
pelvic mobility exercises, it's so incredibly limited,
like that pivot is just, I have no range whatsoever.
I mean, you'll get it.
Once you learn to use the hamstrings,
once you learn how to activate those hamstrings
and we started doing it single leg at a time.
this is where Beth's real brilliance shines,
is just being able to come up with these exercises.
If you just put your foot on a one inch block and elevate
the right foot more than the left
and take turns with the activation,
all of those things start to make it easier for you
to initially get that signal
from your brain to those muscles.
Mm.
I wish I learned this when I was 18,
but I also realize I was too dumb when I was 18.
And there's probably no way I would've done it.
Yeah.
It's that kind of age old question.
What would you tell your younger self,
but that presupposes that your younger self
would be at all open
to like any of this type of advice.
There's simply no way the younger version would of.
Well beyond this kind of realm,
when you think about longevity
and when we talk about longevity,
we're really talking about health span.
What are the other buckets?
And I guess a question that I have
is how does this kind of line up with,
the ideas of the blue zones
and these other kind of principles that guide,
how to think about setting ourselves up
for longevity success?
Well, as you said, lifespan is sort of a,
lifespan and health span are the two vectors of longevity.
But I do think most people think
more about the health span one.
And the good news is they're not independent vectors, right?
These are actually not orthogonal vectors.
Even though we represent them orthogonally on a graph,
if you take all of the steps to live a better life,
they're just invariably going to also lead to a longer life.
Now there are exceptions to this rule.
There are certain trade offs one might make,
if you were really purely optimizing on one or the other,
but the overlap is so powerful.
So I usually tell people not to worry about it.
In other words, if they say,
I don't care how long I live,
I just wanna live the best life possible.
It's like, great.
You're gonna live longer by the way.
So I think of them, as I said, in those three buckets,
sort of a cognitive bucket,
a physical structural bucket and an emotional bucket.
And within that physical bucket, just to kinda round it out,
you have everything we've just spoken about,
which is the stability component.
And that's the foundation.
Everything has to be built upon that.
And then there are,
I sort of think of like three pillars that stand
on the foundation, strength and aerobic base,
which is effectively a proxy for mitochondrial efficiency
and exceptional fuel partitioning,
and then a peak aerobic/anaerobic piece.
So kind of think of your V02 Max,
your zone two and your strength.
And again, I think people have a sort of intuitive sense
of what those look like,
the devil is in the details and you know,
how much time should you be spending
on one versus the other.
And it's really kind of a function
of how much time does is one willing to devote
to this craft.
Right.
I think we,
for understandable reasons probably tell people that they
don't need to do that much exercise,
'cause we're talking to the average person who's doing none.
And it's true that if you're doing no exercise,
just getting you to do three hours a week,
has an unbelievable impact on your life.
Probably more than anything else you could tell
that person to do.
But I would hate for the message to end there
because I think if you could do 10 hours
a week and it's really well structured,
the sky's the limit for what you could achieve.
I wanna put a pin in the zone two discussion.
I wanna get to that later and go deep on that.
So maybe set that aside for now
and we can kind of parse the fitness aspect of this,
the exercise aspect of this,
but when it comes to these other areas,
the emotional area and the cognitive area,
like how are you thinking about practices
in that regard?
I mean the emotional area,
that gets kind of ephemeral, I suppose,
but maybe we'll start with the cognitive stuff.
So the cognitive one really comes down
to a very strong overlap
with how we think about the prevention
of neurodegenerative disease, specifically dementia.
And so we think of kind of these three areas of cognition,
executive function, processing speed and memory,
both short term and long term.
Different forms of dementia
will take on a different assault on each of those things.
And that's become a very interesting study
in the field of neurology.
There was a day when we just thought
of Alzheimer's disease as a disease.
The joke, is not really a joke,
but the joke in neurology is if you've seen one patient
with Alzheimer's disease,
you've seen one patient with Alzheimer's disease.
So I think we're now starting to realize
there's a lot of different subtypes within there,
but we also realize that there are some commonalities
with respect to prevention
and unfortunately or fortunately,
depending on how you think about it,
prevention is kind of our best hope when it comes to that.
This is even more so than cancer
and certainly cardiovascular disease.
We really don't have options
for patients once they have dementia.
Yeah.
This has been an area of extensive study
that has yielded effectively nothing.
If we're going to be brutally honest,
it has yielded effectively nothing.
There are some treatments
that can probably slow down progression,
but the reality is you just wanna be in a position where
you're addressing this even before
we have what's called mild cognitive impairment.
So what do we know about this?
Well, I mean, what we know is exercise
is the single biggest elixir for brain health.
And it's amazing how,
how much more powerful it appears to be
than nutrition, even sleep
and those things are very important,
but exercise is in a league of its own.
And we studied this question extensively
about eight years ago
and I didn't,
I initially just refused to believe this was the answer,
'cause it seemed too simplistic.
I thought there had to be something more powerful.
I thought DHA or something else
could have had a bigger role,
but as important as sleep, nutrition are,
exercise kind of takes the cake.
And I suspect it's because it impacts so many systems.
Right.
So exercise is going to impact glucose disposal,
insulin sensitivity, inflammation.
It produces growth factors for neurons, BDNF.
You tell a person that the most important thing
they can do for their brain health is to exercise.
That's where you get into the hey,
if you could do three hours a week, that's great.
If you can do seven hours a week, it's even better.
Sleep does matter.
With sleep, I think we have,
the problem of sort of one, do you have pathology?
Yes or no, right?
Do you have sleep apnea?
I think there's a lot of undiagnosed sleep apnea out there.
So we kind of have to make sure we're catching those
patients 'cause they don't all look the same, right?
The stereotype is somebody with sleep apnea is overweight
and they're snoring all the time,
but it turns out that there's a lot of sleep apnea
that doesn't fit into that bucket.
So we definitely wanna catch those people.
And then you get into basically duration and quality.
So are you sleeping long enough?
And are you getting appropriate staging?
Nutrition matters of course,
but I think mostly as it fits into metabolic health.
So metabolic health becomes a very important part of this
and then there's the vascular health piece.
So all the things that are kind of good
for the heart are good for the brain.
Sure.
And that means kind of having
the lowest level of Apo B,
or we could sort of loosely talk
about that as LDL cholesterol,
the lower that is the better.
And the more regulated your blood pressure is the better.
The brain is a highly vascular organ.
And it has a lot of the same microvascular structures
that we see in cardiovascular disease.
So the overlap between cardiovascular disease
and dementia is enormous.
Sure, and whether it's cardiovascular disease
or some form of dementia,
these are diseases that are being built
bit by bit for decades.
That's right.
So we can't start thinking about this soon enough,
the earlier in our life that we're adopting the lifestyle
measures required to sidestep these things.
It cannot be overstated.
Yeah, and that's in my view,
probably the biggest single failing
of our medical system today.
What I call medicine 2.0,
is medicine 2.0 is largely
predicated on addressing a risk,
once it reaches a threshold.
So in cardiovascular disease,
we typically use the threshold of 5% at a 10 year
forward looking window.
So once your risk of heart attack, stroke or cardiac death
reaches 5% for the next 10 years,
you are a treatment priority.
And I'll give you an example
of why I think that makes no sense.
So we know that smoking causes lung cancer.
There's no ambiguity that there's a causal relationship
between cigarettes and lung cancer.
So imagine if we said to all smokers out there,
the moment we believe your risk of lung cancer exceeds 5%
over the next decade, we're gonna make you quit smoking.
Conversely, imagine you just said,
the moment you pick up a cigarette,
we're gonna tell you to quit smoking
because smoking is causally related,
totally different framework.
And it's the latter framework that I think
we have to be thinking about for cardiovascular disease
and cerebrovascular disease.
And certainly when you talk about,
health span or longevity,
the low hanging fruit here is dementia,
various forms of dementia, cardiovascular disease, diabetes,
obesity, high blood pressure.
You're not gonna have a long fulfilling life,
if you don't figure out how
to wend your way around these diseases
that are really,
they're the gorillas in the house
that are killing most people.
Yeah, we call them the four horsemen.
So ASCVD, so Atherosclerotic Cardiovascular Disease,
Cancer Neurodegenerative Disease,
and then the whole cluster of metabolic diseases,
which is kind of described it
as a spectrum from insulin resistance,
all the way to type two diabetes and everything in between,
including non-alcoholic fatty liver disease.
Mm.
Which is poised to become the number one indication
for liver transplant in the United States within the decade.
Wow.
(upbeat music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world
is populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know,
who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down the most
compelling profits on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights
gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change: Volume Two."
More than mere words on paper,
voicing change is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the ritual podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change" was a beautifully
rendered book worthy of display on any coffee table
and volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you
to revisit the wisdom of your
favorite everyday prophets and physically interact
with the life changing ideas contained within.
"Voicing Change: Volume Two,"
available now while supplies last
for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
How does your sense of health span medicine,
if that is a term,
how does that square with some of the stuff
that we're seeing now in terms
of technological and scientific breakthroughs in this area?
Everything from like,
if you're part of the singularity university,
it's all about like scanning technology.
And like, I was just at a conference in San Diego
the other month.
And there were people who are like 3D printing,
human lungs and all kinds of crazy stuff.
That's very different from where your focus is.
So how are you thinking about this in a way that perhaps
matches or does not match
what we're seeing from people like David Sinclair
and his kind of opponent in that realm?
Charles Brenner.
Yeah, look, I mean,
I think David and Charles basically go back and forth
about two different molecules, right?
NR and NMN as precursors for NAD.
And again, I would say no disrespect to them,
but that's like rearranging the deck chairs
on the Titanic compared to exercise.
So look, I would say that the data
for the efficacy of NR and NMN
as a tool to boost longevity, is non existent
at this point in time.
And that's not from a lack of testing.
I mean the interventions testing program at the NIH,
which is hands down the most rigorous tool
we have for testing is different interventions,
namely pharmaceutical molecules,
unequivocally showed that NR did not work.
Mm.
So if there are benefits to NR and NMN,
we haven't seen them yet.
And I would argue that if they do exist,
they're not going to be that big.
They're certainly not going to be on the order
of what we see with exercise.
I don't think people
and I don't mean not to come back to exercise.
I'm not talking about it 'cause it's like fun
and it's 'cause it's easy,
I'm talking about it 'cause the magnitude is insane.
The difference in risk between a person who's VO2 Max
is in the top 2.5% for their age and sex,
to someone who's in the bottom 25%.
So think about that, right?
You're in the bottom 25% for your age, which is like,
you're an inactive person versus you're in the top 2.5%,
which isn't otherworldly by the way,
like you and I are probably in the top 2.5%
for our age group.
It's a fivefold difference
in accruing risk of all cause mortality.
Wow.
So let's pretend you don't have to be that extreme.
What's the difference in risk between somebody
who's in the bottom 25%
and someone who's in the third quartile,
it's still a three X difference.
Right, and if you're going from completely sedentary.
You can get there.
Yeah.
Very quickly.
Yes.
It's interesting how the human,
animal is wired though.
It's like, ooh, you know,
here's a compound that's gonna solve this problem
when really the biggest lever
is sitting right in front of us the whole time.
Yeah, I was kind of joking about this with,
with Andrew Huberman the other day, which was,
I wish they would just create a rule that says
you're not even allowed to argue on Twitter
about a molecule until you're exercising 10 hours a week.
Like once you've shown
that you can work out 10 hours a week,
then you've earned the right to bicker about,
vitamin D or this or that,
or the other thing is beneficial.
Right.
So your Twitter account is sort of Bluetooth linked
to your garment or something like that.
And it won't activate until you've put that time in.
Yeah, and look,
this is not from a moment to suggest
that I am not incredibly excited
about the molecule side of this.
I think rapamycin is hands down though,
the most important and exciting
and promising neuroprotective molecule.
Yeah, why don't you speak about that.
We can spend a couple minutes on that.
Sure, yeah.
So rapamycin is a compound
that was actually discovered remarkably
serendipitously on Easter Island in the 1960s.
They didn't know what they had at the time.
And it was sort of purified from the bacteria
that were found in the soil there in the 1970s
and ultimately produced a drug
that was a potent immunosuppressant.
So it suppressed the proliferation of T cells.
And in the late nineties was approved by the FDA for use
in patients with organ transplants.
But a decade later, another discovery was made,
which was actually, if you dosed it a bit,
a little differently, it was a very potent longevity agent.
So potent in fact that it did something no drug or molecule
had ever done before or has ever done since,
which is it extends life in every organism
across the entire spectrum of eukaryotic models.
So yeast, worms, fruit flies, mice.
We now see it in even other organisms.
And again, it does so without contradiction.
So we just see this over and over and over again.
And that's a very rare feature in science.
And it's been around for many years, decades.
20 Plus years.
So there is some data sets
on the impact of human life
over time in the context of organ transplant,
but it's not FDA approved for any kind of longevity purpose.
Correct?
Yeah, so any, so I take it,
and a number of my patients do
and obviously that's off label, right?
So, you can,
anything that's FDA approved you can use,
but the way we use it is very different
from the way a patient uses it for organ transplant.
So a patient for organ transplants is taking kind
of a medium dose every day,
based on all of the literature it appear
and including human literature that has studied ways
to boost immune function with it.
It appears that a higher dose once a week produces
the opposite effect, which is better immune function
and obviously the longevity phenotype.
And so how long have you been using it
and are there noticeable effects?
So I've been probably using it for four years.
And for me,
there are not any noticeable effects.
I have some patients who,
I would say half the people who take it,
maybe a third really claim to feel different.
Mm.
But I don't think that's the norm.
And you know,
you can never know how to discount placebo effect.
It might, I talked to another doctor,
who's prescribed it quite a bit.
He has a much sicker patient population than me.
And he claims that many of his patients
feel significantly better.
So it might be a function of your kind of baseline health
coming in, but I don't truthfully feel anything.
So in that sense,
it is purely a leap of faith based on a legion of data.
Yeah, Yeah.
You've mentioned a couple times.
We've looked into this, we're studying this.
One of the other kind of differentiators
around you and your practice
is that you have this head of research
and you have a whole team of people
and you're going through all the papers that are getting
published all the time and coming up with your own studies
to look at the things that interest you in this field.
So what are some of the studies that you're currently
to look at right now in doing yourself
or what do you think are
the big studies that we could do
or should be doing right now,
to really get greater clarity on in this field?
I think one of the interesting questions
that we've got funding for.
I think we've got the funding to launch it.
We're just kind of waiting for the backlog
on some of the COVID related IRB stuff,
with Iñigo San Millán is to do a study,
looking at the use of Metformin
in really metabolically healthy people.
So as you know,
there's lots of data suggesting that Metformin
in non-diabetic patients could extend life.
So there's a big study that Nir Barzilai
is leading the charge on called the TAME study.
That is basically asking the question,
if you give Metformin to people, will they live longer?
Nondiabetics.
So that's a very important question.
Looks like he just got funding to complete that finally
about three weeks ago, that was announced.
But my experience with Metformin
has been a little different.
So I took Metformin for probably eight years on the basis
of all of the epidemiologic data
that looked really promising
that Metformin is especially going to prevent cancer.
But once I got really nerdy on my zone two training
and was really tracking lactate levels
and doing all sorts of stuff,
I just couldn't help
but wonder was Metformin potentially poisoning my
mitochondria just a little bit, which is again,
perhaps part of how it works in the diabetic,
but is that counterbalancing what I'm doing that's positive.
In other words,
if you take somebody who's sedentary diabetic,
that might be a worthwhile trade up,
'cause the net benefit is so positive,
but in someone like me,
I don't need the glycemic control, is this a negative?
So for that reason, I just sort of stopped Metformin.
And basically in our practice over the last few years,
we have sort of phased out the use of Metformin in patients
who are healthy and who are exercising.
And frankly, even in patients
who are metabolically unhealthy,
but whom we're able to push down the exercise pathway.
I've been on the let's not even bother with Metformin.
But the reality of it is I want to know
the answer to this question.
And I want to know it very specifically in a subset
of people like you and I.
So if you take people who are,
gonna be willing to ride their bike four hours a week,
can we do a complete proteomic metabolomic muscle biopsy
based study where we truly look at the impact of Metformin,
functionally at the mitochondria.
And Íñigo being this sort of lord of all things, Z2.
Yeah, yeah.
So Íñigo is super keen to do this.
And it was just a question of could we procure the funding,
which we were able to do pretty quickly.
Interesting.
Because my patients love to figure out ways
to fund this type of research 'cause you know,
you're not gonna get the NIH to fund that.
Right.
Your studies are all being privately funded.
That's right.
You're not part of the whole grant stuff.
That's right, we're basically saying,
look, I mean, we can raise this money privately in days.
Why would we subject the investigators
to beating their heads against the wall
to justify something?
And what does that pitch to the investor?
Like what are they getting out of it?
The knowledge of this?
It's actually.
It's purely a knowledge based thing.
Absolutely, yeah.
Interesting.
Let's talk about metabolic health.
In the kind of context
of technological advances and developments.
Now we have all these wearables,
we have the Oura Ring and I've got the WHOOP on
and I've been playing around
with Inside Tracker and I've got my levels patched on.
I see that.
And it's got me,
there's pluses and minuses to all of these things.
One thing that all of these devices
have been really good at is getting me very engaged
with how my health is doing
on a day-to-day basis, which is great.
But I do feel like I'm suffering from kind of this lay
person's condition of not knowing
what all of this data means or what to do with it.
And I think there's a lot of confusion out there
about what's meaningful versus
what is something we don't need to be concerned with,
but I want to kind of structure this around the subject
matter of metabolic health.
So perhaps like define what it is and you know,
in kind of the context of healthy metabolic function,
versus metabolic dysfunction.
I think the easiest way to start
is a very broad definition that would encompass something
called metabolic syndrome.
So in the ,gosh, 1980s, maybe even early nineties,
a very, very famous and amazing endocrinologist
at Stanford guy named Jerry Reaven.
He would've been there when you were there.
Jerry died probably about four years ago.
I was very lucky to meet him several times before he did.
And the guy was insanely generous with his time.
Like I literally just go to his office
and hang out with him and ask him questions.
He kind of identified something that at the time he referred
to as syndrome X, which he said,
this thing tends to cluster around all diseases
that are kind of metabolic in origin,
cardiovascular disease,
cancer, neurodegenerative disease, diabetes, fatty liver,
although we didn't know about fatty liver at the time,
all of these things tend to cluster around this thing,
he called syndrome X.
And without going through the details of how that migrated,
what we now know is he was referring to insulin resistance
and what we now call metabolic syndrome.
So metabolic syndrome is defined in a very crude way,
but everything that's done at the population level
is incredibly crude.
So it's basically defined by how big your waste is,
how high your blood pressure is, how high your glucose is,
how high your triglycerides are
and how low your HDL cholesterol is.
And there's sort of a line drawn in the sand
that says if three, four or five of those metrics
are beyond a threshold,
you have met syn, you have metabolic syndrome.
And of course it's a continuum.
So I used to know the stats very well.
What fraction of the population had five outta five,
which would be, very bad, four outta five,
and what fraction of the population
had like zero out of five.
And so if you lined up everybody
in the country across that spectrum,
you're going from the most metabolically healthy
to the least metabolically healthy.
But I haven't really answered the question for you.
I've just kind of labeled it.
So what does it actually mean?
And think the best way that I can explain it
is through fuel partitioning.
So fuel partitioning is basically a fancy way of saying,
how does your body know what to do
with the energy you put in it?
Where does it put it and how does it access it later?
And someone like you, someone like me,
like our bodies are pretty good at doing this.
We know when you eat glucose, fat, protein,
this part we should use, this part we should store.
And when we go to exercise,
we know how to access the right one.
So this is where kind of zone two comes back into it.
Zone two is basically a test
of your mitochondrial efficiency.
And this is one of the hallmarks of aging, right?
So there are nine hallmarks of aging
and one of them is mitochondrial dysfunction.
We just know that as we get older,
our mitochondria get less and less effective.
And what you really want are mitochondria
that can access fat stores at basically higher
and higher levels of work output.
So an example of a metabolically healthy person
to a metabolically unhealthy person,
is have them go for a walk.
The metabolically healthy person is accessing exclusively
fat stores to do that.
The metabolically unhealthy person is burning through
glucose and glycogen to make that happen.
That's a fundamental distinction between them.
Sure.
And the trade off of that
is what's the natural history of that?
This person is getting fatter and this person
is having a harder and harder time
regulating their glucose levels.
Right.
So the more dysregulated you are,
the more likely you are to gain weight.
It just becomes like a vicious cycle
that gets worse and worse.
Yeah, and then it really gets worse and worse
because the weight gaining part on the surface ,
is what people kind of get worked up about,
oh my God, like I'm getting fatter.
But the reality of it is it's not this subcutaneous fat,
that's the problem.
It's not the fat that we see on our waist.
It's the fat that we don't see, that's the problem.
Called the sort of the extra,
so this is called subcutaneous fat.
So if you take the extra subcutaneous fat depots,
like visceral fat, the fat that surrounds your organs,
the fat that accumulates around the pancreas, the kidneys,
the heart, within the muscle itself,
and I'm talking right within the muscle cells,
that's the fat that's incredibly destructive.
And that can represent a tiny fraction of your total fat.
If a person has 20 pounds of fat,
let's say 20 kilos of fat on a 200 per pound person,
from a body fat perspective,
probably put them at the 25th percentile,
they're pretty run of the mill.
But if only 10% of that fat
were out of their subcutaneous stores,
that would place them at the 90th percentile
for visceral fat.
Hmm.
And that's the dangerous fat,
that's the inflammatory fat,
that's the fat that's truly wreaking havoc
with respect to metabolic illness.
Right, so typically if somebody
is suffering from metabolic syndrome
and they go to their general practitioner,
that person is likely to say
your blood pressure's high, you're prediabetic.
We need to put you on this battery of medications.
You have patients in which
they're displaying similar characteristics.
You put them on a lifestyle protocol
to try to basically reduce these factors
and get their metabolic health in check.
So explain a little bit about what that process is
and just how malleable metabolic health is.
Fortunately it is quite malleable and there are,
different ways that we go about doing it
depending on what we think are the contributing factors.
So sleep, nutrition,
exercise and pharmacology,
would be the main contributing factors.
Now the fifth thing that we always think about
is emotional health.
And for some people that can be an enormously contributing
factor both directly and also,
and more commonly indirectly.
There's a stress a component of that emotional health.
Yeah.
And so stress directly
just through its endocrine function, right?
So hipercolesterolemia is completely destructive
to your metabolic health in excess.
So transient stress, not so much an issue,
but this chronic elevation of cortisol,
is incredibly destructive for insulin resistance
and all sorts of other things.
But more importantly and more subtly is,
it's the emotional health bucket that gets in the way
of making some of the behavioral changes
in these other buckets.
Nobody has a hard time taking medicine.
And the reality is you can fix a lot of numbers
with the medicine,
but you're not getting as much of a benefit
as if you fix them sort of with food, sleep and exercise.
So when we're trying to evaluate, so let's say,
the hypothetical patient comes in and everything is wrong.
So then the next question is why,
what are the contributing factors?
Sleep is the first thing we always wanna look at,
'cause it's the easiest one to assess pretty quickly.
So again, to your point,
most of our patients are wearing an Oura Ring.
So that's provides some information.
We use some sleep surveys that are pretty well vetted,
so there's probably four or five of them.
And depending on what we see on the Oura data
and what we see in the sleep surveys,
we then might move to another test to look for,
like an at home test that can give us
a very quick view on apnea.
And depending on what we see there,
we might move to a more formal sleep study.
And so we're kind of going through, is there pathology?
Yes or no?
Are you over slept or under slept?
Yes or no.
If you're under slept,
are you also dysregulated with staging?
And we kind of have just an entire rabbit hole.
We go down with sleep that involves
sleep hygiene, that involves supplements.
And sometimes frankly includes medications.
There's a prescription drug
called Trazodone that really helps
people who are dysregulated
in their sleep because of rumination.
So it's a non-habit forming amazing drug
that more importantly,
preserves sleep architecture.
Most sleep drugs don't really preserve
sleep architecture that well.
Right.
On the nutrition front,
we're asking the first order question is,
are you over nourished or undernourished?
And are you, obviously you're metabolically unhealthy.
We wouldn't be having this discussion.
So over nourished, undernourished,
usually if you're metabolically unhealthy,
you're also over nourished.
And then the next question is, are you over muscled?
Pardon me under muscled or adequately muscled.
And that plays a hugely important role for our protein
strategy and our training strategy.
And then once we sort of go through the well,
presumably you're over nourished,
let's say you're also under muscled.
Let's make it really hard,
'cause that's a really difficult reconciliation.
If someone's over nourished and under muscled,
they have to lose weight and gain muscle.
So now you need a lot of protein and a lot of training.
The question then becomes what is the strategy
for intake reduction?
You have three strategies, caloric restriction,
dietary restriction, time restriction,
and go into all the details
of the pros and cons of each one.
On the exercise front,
it really depends on what they're doing to begin with.
Each type of exercise has its benefit,
but if you're talking about a person
who's starting from zero, we're mostly working on movement,
stability and zone two.
I'm not gonna push them into VO2 Max,
not gonna let them get hurt
trying to do any significant strength training.
It's how do we fix the chassis,
so that we can make the car drive faster and faster.
Right.
And in those patients,
literally just putting them on a treadmill and walking them,
up an incline can be very beneficial.
So assuming high patient adherence to these protocols,
what is the timeframe in which you can take somebody
who is fairly dysregulated into a zone of relative safety?
Yeah, again, it's all comes down to adherence.
I think back to a patient that joined our practice
about a year ago, liver function tests,
on arrival were,
3X, 4X, normal,
demonstrating lots of fatty liver disease,
very high degree of insulin resistance.
We do something called an oral glucose tolerance test
with everyone that comes in the door.
So they drink a big glucose drink.
And then we measure glucose and insulin spikes
for the next couple of hours.
I think this patient probably within six months
had those things reversed
and then this patient was incredibly diligent.
This patient was doing everything that was asked.
I'm less wed to how long it takes and more wed
to can we create sustainable things that if it takes a year,
but you found a groove that is sustainable.
Right.
That's more important to me
than trying to fix it in three months.
Yeah, interesting.
I've had just some interesting revelations
in my own experimentation
wearing a CGM, noticing,
when and how I go out of my sort of zone.
I noticed that when I was experimenting with one meal a day,
that was a disaster,
especially when that one meal a day comes very late.
Disregulates my sleep and the spikes were crazy
and they don't come down quickly.
And I was like, and I've been doing that for a while.
And I was like, I have to stop doing this.
So there's been really helpful kind of feedback
that I've gotten from this.
But I also admit to not really knowing
how to interpret this data, like when I spike,
if it comes down relatively quickly,
should I be concerned about that?
Or what should I, and I think this is like a,
a danger with a lot of these trackable types of things,
is it gives us all this data,
but there's less focus on like what to do with the data
and really to kind of figure out,
what is meaningful in all of this.
So what should I be thinking about
and what are some of the common misconceptions
or misinterpretation of wearable data?
So the short answer is we don't know
because we haven't had these wearables for long.
So it's a really new phenomenon to be able to send people
into the wild and measure their glucose continuously.
So one has to acknowledge that and then say,
well, based on that,
how can we extrapolate from what is known?
And so our team did some amazing work on this,
about a year and a half ago.
It was about six months worth of effort
to look at all of the literature around three issues
of glucose, outside of the setting of type two diabetes.
So we absolutely know in the setting of type two diabetes
that a higher average glucose is worse.
That is the definition of the metric
that we use to make the diagnosis of the disease.
The diagnosis is made based on something
called the hemoglobin A1C, which is a crude,
but not horrible way to estimate the backwards
looking average blood glucose of an individual.
So if a person's hemoglobin A1C is 5.0%,
that tells you,
that's giving you an estimate of how much glucose
has stuck to their red blood cells,
that tells you over the past three months,
their average glucose was about 98 milligrams per deciliter,
which is excellent.
That's your average blood glucose
over all your ins and outs.
Once that average, once that hemoglobin A1C reaches 6.5%,
that tells us that the estimated
looking back over the past three month
average glucose is 140 milligrams per deciliter.
Now you have type two diabetes, congratulations.
Now, of course, to me this is a continuum.
This is another example of where I think it makes
no sense to wait 'til someone has type two diabetes
to sound the alarm.
So in our practice.
I'll back up for a second.
So then the question became,
what do we know about the difference between having a blood
sugar that averages 100 versus one that averages 130,
neither of those people have type two diabetes?
Is there a difference?
And I think if you look at the data,
the answer is unambiguously clear.
Lower is better.
The next question became what can be said about variability.
So if, I don't know if the levels one does this,
but on the Dexcom meter, which is the one we prefer,
just because you can calibrate it and it's more accurate.
Is that the one that's with Libre?
No. Libre, I think is the Abbott one,
which I'm not particularly fond of.
Okay.
Because you can't calibrate it.
I just think it's a less accurate meter,
but the next thing you can look at
is not just your average glucose,
but you can look at the standard deviation.
So you can look back and say over the past day,
the past week, the past month, the past 90 days,
how much variability existed?
And so then again, we looked at that question,
which is can the literature tell us
anything about variability of glucose?
And the answer appears to be yes,
less variability is better.
And then the final question,
which is probably the hardest to ask,
and I don't think we know an answer to this is,
are there downsides of transient spikes.
Now, a spike is inevitable.
Meaning anytime you eat glucose
or any form of carbohydrate,
your glucose has to go up.
So the question is, does it matter how high it goes?
I don't think we know the answer
to that question, truthfully.
So, we've basically said, look,
what if we could just arbitrarily say,
keeping your spikes below 140 to 150,
is better than keeping them below 200,
because the reality of it is,
I'm not really aware of a scenario,
whereby you eat good food and your glucose
goes to 200, but I'm aware of how to make,
I could make my glucose go to 200 like that if you gave me
enough Raisinettes,
but I can't really make it happen by eating beans.
And is that more important or less important
than how quickly it comes back down to baseline?
I think of the three metrics that we care about,
average glucose, variability of glucose
and just the number or frequency of spikes,
I would say that the frequency of spikes
is probably the least important.
In other words,
I don't think there's any physiologic harm
that comes from a transient spike to 200 by itself.
So if I could just sort of robotically say
your glucose went to 200
and then it came back to a hundred in an hour.
Fine.
The reality is it doesn't do that though.
What happens is if it goes to 200, it's gonna come,
you're gonna overshoot,
'cause you're gonna have secreted a pound
of insulin into your circulation.
When it comes down,
it doesn't stop at a hundred.
Yeah, it's gonna go to 40 probably not 40,
probably go to 60.
And what's the effect of that on your appetite.
What's the effect of that on the bounce back.
And that's why in my experience,
and this is just clinical experience,
just banging away with patients over the last six years,
when we suggest to patients that our metric
is avoid spikes over 140 to 150,
try to keep your average at a hundred,
try to keep your standard deviation below 15.
Eat around that.
Let that determine your carbohydrate tolerance.
People just do really, really well.
Right, right, right.
So this is very empirical
and everyone will have a different
carbohydrate tolerance, right?
It's a function of your sleep, your stress,
your metabolic health, your exercise.
It is interesting how much sleep comes into play.
Like if I don't sleep well.
Oh, your numbers are horrible.
It's terrible.
Yeah.
All over the map.
And I thought, well, is that because of the poor sleep
or is the lack of stability contributing to the poor sleep?
If you look at the experimental data,
I'm trying to blank out a name.
I think it's Eve van Cauter,
she's a researcher at the University of Chicago.
Did a pretty elegant experiment.
Took a group of people and I'm probably gonna get
a few of these details wrong.
'Cause it's been a few reason since I looked at it.
So did what's called a Euglycemic clamp
So this is the gold standard
for measuring glucose, disposal and insulin sensitivity.
So people are run with a line
that runs insulin and glucose into them.
And they're given glucose and insulin
such that they have to maintain a Euglycemic
or normal glycemic response.
So there's just no blips on a flat line.
Right, and then the question
is how much insulin do you require to do that?
So that now tells you exactly
how insulin sensitive a person is.
And this is pinpoint accuracy
because that's basically telling
you in real time,
how effective are this person's muscles
at sensing insulin and taking glucose out of circulation,
'cause your muscles are what take your glucose out
of circulation in the short run.
So you do this test on people and then they were sleep,
it was a crossover group.
So a control and then a crossover.
And the intervention was,
I wanna say two weeks of sleep deprivation
to four hours a night, which by the way,
like that was my residency for five years.
So that's not an unreasonable intervention.
And then repeat the glycemic clamp
and glucose disposal fell by 50%.
Wow.
So in two weeks of admittedly really bad sleep,
you're taking somebody halfway to diabetes.
So now imagine a person whose sleep
is compromised for years.
So that's why going back to what we said at the outset,
if you're not looking at a person's sleep
with real seriousness,
before you try to address their metabolic health,
you could be missing a wolf standing at your door.
But the good news, of course,
being this malleability piece that it can be corrected.
And you know, in the context of a culture
where it appears that by 2030,
something like 50% of Americans are gonna be either
prediabetic diabetic or diabetic,
is this not the most important thing
to be thinking about tracking and talking about?
Yeah, look, I've gotten into some real battles
with people over this 'cause I've
been a very vocal advocate for the use of continuous glucose
monitors and everything from trolls on Twitter.
There's a weird Twitter war going on over this,
which is confusing to me.
Yeah, and there was an article written in Gamma Health
a year ago that came down on the side
of there's no role for using
continuous glucose monitors in non-diabetics,
and again, I think people are not understanding
how to use these things clinically.
Right, I mean that's part of why I'm asking.
I do think that there is a lot of room that remains
in the education space
to help people like myself understand
how to interpret the data.
Yeah, and in that sense, I'm actually empathetic.
And I understand why saying like let's slow down a little
bit and let's make sure,
'cause again, I think our patients
have a very different experience.
I've been using one of these things
since 2015 on myself, almost continuously.
You can imagine how many reps I have
and by extension our patients.
And so we know how to use this data to do two things,
one to gain insights into how to change,
people's eating and two,
to use it as a behavior tool
to then create compliance over time.
Those are two different things,
but they're equally valuable.
I don't, sorry, go ahead.
Oh no, I was gonna say, but that said,
I don't think that that experience is shared
by somebody who just goes
and order one of these things online.
So again, I can understand why it can create
a lot of confusion for people
if they don't have that insight.
Yeah, I mean, it does.
There's a weird psychological thing
that happens 'cause you're
essentially gamifying your nutrition, right?
And so you look at this,
this interface and you see where you're supposed to be
and you ate this thing and you're out of it
and you're like, you make a metal note.
Okay, I won't eat that thing.
And then it's become like, how flat can I make my curve?
And like how,
but there is an engagement there that I can't imagine
is a negative thing.
Like you are connected to what's happening in your body
in real time and with the appropriate amount of education.
But the flip side is,
and this is a fair criticism.
So I think when I,
I wrote a piece on this a little over a year ago
and one of the people who criticized me,
who I've since engaged with quite a bit
and I think he made a fair point,
which I could have been more explicit
and should have been,
which is if a person looks at their CGM data in isolation,
they can still make a mistake.
So I'll use an analogy that I,
I don't know if I've since gone back
and rewritten about this,
but I've certainly talked about it.
If I said to you Rich,
the only metric that matters in life
is the number on the scale.
And lower is better.
If I program that into your mind,
there's no reason you wouldn't take up smoking.
You're probably gonna lose weight, right?
So in isolation,
maniacally focusing on one metric
can easily lead you to do bad things
along the way and this is no exception.
So, I think the glib example is,
well, if I ate,
if I literally ate nothing but bacon every single day.
Just nothing but fat, like you'll keep your.
You'll keep your glucose low.
I'm not convinced that that's an ideal diet
Right, sure, sure.
So that's why I think I would say this has to be viewed
in the context of everything that you're doing.
And there has to be kind of a whole set of common sense
principles that go into this along with just,
this is the only number that matters.
Right, got it.
Let's segue into zone two.
My favorite topic of all time.
It's so hilarious that like zone two training
is now like a thing that people love to talk about.
Like I've been talking about this forever.
Yeah, Philip Maffetone has been talking
about it under different names.
Yeah, so I caught on to the Maffetone method
at the beginning of my ultra endurance training
and I really credit adherence,
strict, strict adherence to that philosophy
as a vehicle for me,
making drastic improvements over the course
of three year period.
This stuff doesn't happen overnight
and I'm constantly preaching the benefits of it.
And it's so cool and interesting
to see people experiment with it.
But I think there's also a lot of confusion
about what it actually is and why it's effective.
So nobody is better, except for maybe Iñigo.
Is that how you say his name?
Iñigo
Iñigo.
Yeah.
At talking about this.
Please allow me to indulge you
in a conversation about zone two training.
So I agree.
I wish there was a better name for it because as you know,
'cause you've trained with a power meter on a bike.
If you're a student of cycling power meters,
we use seven zones when we're training and cycling.
And so the first thing I say to anybody who's coming to this
is please forget everything you know
about your numbers and your zones.
And this has nothing to do with FTP
and the sort of Andrew Cogan sort of stuff.
So it's just an energy system.
And the way Sam Milan describes it is really through five
energy systems and zone two is the one
that is basically defined
as the maximal level of aerobic output,
that you can generate while keeping lactate
below two millimole.
So you could argue that's an arbitrary definition,
although physiologically, it turns out not to be.
So what is lactate?
We have to kind of explain this,
I think in some detail for people
to understand why this matters,
because even though most people will do zone two,
without ever measuring their lactate and that's fin,.
if you want to be really on the money,
you do need to measure your lactate at least periodically.
And I do every day.
I mean I do zone two, four days a week,
every one of those four days a week,
I'm measuring my lactate.
There's plenty of DIY protocols out there
that vary in terms of efficacy,
but I'm always encouraging people to get a proper test
on a bike trainer or on a treadmill
with a technician who's drawing lactate at those intervals.
So you can really dial in on it.
And I wrote about this in my book
and I explained that my,
the top of my zone two, was a heart rate
of like 145, I think when I was running
and 130 on a bike and then people will tweet me and like,
I'm keeping my heart rate at 145.
I'm like, no,
this is not what I'm saying.
I expressly said like, this is me.
Yeah.
This is not, you,
You have to get a proper test to really
understand your own physiology.
Yeah, so this gets back to your question
about metabolic health.
Well, zone two in many ways
is the most important functional test
we have for determining a person's metabolic health.
So I talk to patients about how we have dynamic
and static tests for determining their health.
So a static test is just a blood test where tell me what
your uric acid is, your glucose, your insulin,
all of these things, your triglycerides.
A dynamic test is let me give you a bunch of glucose
right now and draw your blood over time
and watch what it does.
Another dynamic test is, let me ask you to do work,
ride a bike, run on a treadmill,
and let me measure a metabolic byproduct called lactate.
And that will tell me an unbelievable amount,
perhaps more than anything else,
about how you function
and this functional test is so important.
So when our bodies create ATP,
they have choices for what fuel they're going to use.
So for all intents and purposes,
there are two fuels to make ATP, glucose and fat.
Now with fat, you can only do one thing with it.
You can only turn fat into two carbon subunits
that get put into the mitochondria
where you very efficiently make ATP,
carbon dioxide and water vapor.
So that's why when we're,
so the input is fat and oxygen
and the output is ATP carbon dioxide water.
So we're breathing out CO2 and water vapor.
We're using the ATP.
We can do the same thing with glucose.
Glucose can be turned from,
glucose into pyruvate,
and pyruvate goes into that same pathway.
So glucose and fat can both be churned through that super
efficient pathway to make ATP .
As the body's demand for ATP grows,
it's going to start out stripping
the capacity of the mitochondria,
depending on the fitness of the individual,
depending on the efficiency of the furnace.
And so it does have an escape valve.
It does have a manner in which it can produce more ATP,
absent sufficient oxygen which is basically the thing,
the utilization of oxygen becomes the bottleneck.
But you can't do it with fat.
So once you tap out on your fat stores,
you don't have a way to over spill fat oxidation
into this other energy source.
Instead, you turn that glucose into pyruvate
but now you turn the pyruvate into lactate
and that does yield a little bit of ATP,
literally about 1/16th the ATP you would've received,
if you had run that glucose through the mitochondria.
So that's a knock on it.
That's the trade off is you got a fraction of the energy,
but the bigger trade off is that you're generating lactate,
which now pairs with hydrogen and creates an acid,
that acid effectively makes it very difficult
for actin, myosin filaments to uncouple.
And if that lactic acid level gets high enough,
you start to really feel the inability,
the burn in the muscle that creates the inability
for you to continue effectively contracting your muscles.
So anybody who's done an all out effort knows
exactly what that feels like.
Sure.
The other variability being the exhaustibility
of the energy source, right?
You have like something like 45 minutes worth of glucose
output at that higher zone training rate,
whereas your fat stores
are essentially inexhaustible.
That's right.
Right?
So if you can develop a vast zone two capacity,
which essentially means being able to be incredibly
metabolically efficient at a certain activity,
at a certain level of exertion,
that in turn creates mitochondrial efficiency,
mitochondrial density, and exten,
basically an inexhaustible source of energy
to propel you through an ultra endurance event
or an endurance event.
Yep.
And so I thought about this a lot,
obviously when I was swimming,
because even more so than cycling,
fueling in really long swims, as you now know,
it's a grind,
especially in the ocean where the salt water
gets in your mouth.
On one of my Catalina swims,
I remember it was so choppy that on one breath,
I turned to breathe,
it was the middle of the night.
So you can't see anything and just ingested
a gallon of salt water.
Nausea is a given.
Yeah, you're just puking your brains out.
So anything you can do to minimize the requirement
for having to feed the glucose engine,
especially when you can't really take in a solution
in excess of about 6% glucose, 60 grams per liter,
you're very limited at how much glucose you can take in.
So, absolutely correct.
Okay, so now the question becomes
what separates men from the boys.
Basically when you look at endurance sports,
one of the most differentiating factors,
is how high is a person's zone two threshold.
Let's just use cycling as an example,
'cause it's just so easy to metric.
How many watts can a person generate
per kilo of body weight, if we wanna normalize it,
while keeping lactate below two.
And what is it about that lactate below two?
If lactate stays below two,
you are at that equilibrium where we know
that you are in balance.
You are not net accumulating lactate yet.
Once lactate gets above two,
you will begin to net accumulate lactate,
meaning you will accumulate lactate
quicker than you can clear it.
And that now puts you in a finite strategy of activity.
Now, when you and I did races and stuff like that,
like when I was in a time trial,
my lactate was definitely above two.
I would finish a race at a lactate of 16
and probably 10 minutes before the end,
my lactate was eight and 10 minutes before that my lactate
was probably four.
I sort of budgeted to blow up at the end of that race.
But if you said to me, Peter,
I want you to go out and do a three hour nonstop ride
at your maximum.
Like what's the fastest,
what's the greatest distance you could cover in three hours.
I have to keep lactate below two.
In fact, when you look at Kipchoge
breaking a two hour marathon record, same thing.
Even though he's running at a speed,
most of us can't run for a hundred yards,
for him, his lactate was below two.
Sure.
To be able to do that or else he couldn't have done that.
Yeah, it's interesting that that terminology
like VO2 Max gets all the attention.
And in reality it's so much less important
than what your Z2 maximum is.
And a question that I don't know,
that I've ever heard a good answer for,
that I'm curious about is,
is the difference between, like, let's say your,
let's say the top end of your zone too is like,
I don't know, 250 Watts on a bike.
What is the difference between an athlete that can maintain
that 250 Watts at below two at below two,
for three hours,
but then taps out,
versus the athlete that can maintain that for eight hours?
At some point it starts to become a question
of like how much fuel can they,
how much fuel can they,
'cause you're still, the three eight hour difference,
you're gonna have to start ingesting
some fuel at that point.
So assume, assume, equality across fueling.
Yeah, then it probably starts to come down
to muscle fibers and things like that, at eight hours.
Mitochondrial density.
I don't know that.
I don't think I know the answer to that.
I think what I would say is you're going to,
because these are fit athletes,
like their muscles are actually putting out a lot of power.
250 Watts is a lot of power.
And so I think you're now starting
to get into the limitations of actual fiber damage.
For example, like when people feel sore
the day after a super intense
workout where they had that lactate burn,
I think they erroneously assume that it's the lactate
that they're feeling, but they're actually not,
they're feeling the microscopic damage to the muscle fibers.
So I suspect that that's probably going to be
the differentiating factor there.
So it's some amount of muscle
protein synthesis and some amount
of kind of strength that probably factors into it as well.
Yeah.
Like actual muscular strength.
I remember when I was training for,
for my first Ultraman.
Prior to that, I'd messed around in
triathlon without a coach.
Was pretty fit in my own mind.
Hired a coach.
He's like, I can't even tell you anything
until you get a lactate test.
Like there's no point in us even talking,
I need you to go do this.
I didn't know anything about it.
And I was like, ah, I'll be good.
Like I go in, that graph was like pathetic.
I couldn't believe like how quickly
I would go out of zone two.
And then my whole program was built upon,
this church of zone two where literally for the first year,
I don't think I did a single workout
that was above zone two.
How much did your zone two increase
during that course of the year?
Unbelievable.
The improvement was insane.
Yeah.
And that's why I became like,
I'm such an adherent and a believer in this.
Without doing any threshold or tempo work whatsoever,
I was able to go from somebody
who couldn't run faster than 10 minutes per mile,
without going into zone three,
to two years later,
being able to run like seven fifteens in my zone too,
without any track work, without any threshold work,
any interval work, whatsoever.
Just by building that foundation bit by bit.
And it's all about the ability to come back the next day
and the next day and the next day.
And I think there's something about that consistency,
such that when you develop that robustness
and you do have an effort,
let's say you're attacking a hill or whatever,
and you're way out of your zone too to do so,
you come back down to that baseline zone too,
very quickly, as opposed to like,
being winded for an extended period of time
and kind of losing pace as a result.
Yeah, so when we put our patients through CPET testing,
we have about a four page dashboard
that we run them through,
which is much more extensive than just,
We show you your VO2 Max,
and we will tell you why that's important,
but it's also, what is your fat oxidation?
How many grams per minute of fat,
can you oxidize and over what power range
and what is the shape of your curve?
And we benchmark this against like athletes.
So Iñigo's given us data, right?
So here's the guy who won the tour de France.
Here's a master's athlete.
Here's somebody with metabolic syndrome.
And where do you stack up?
So you can really start to see how you oxidize fat
and how many watts per kilo you can put out
at zone two compared to these varying degrees of spectrum.
So now all of a sudden, I'm not just saying, yeah,
here's your glucose and here's your insulin
and here's your triglyceride levels.
But I think this is a much more important test
because of its functionality.
Right.
It does require a lot of humility though,
and you have to play the long game with it.
And most people like,
what's your two year plan?
They're like, well,
I wanna do this race in a month
or three months or something like that.
Like you really have to be patient with it.
Yeah.
And again, it fits so well
into the centenarian decathlon because,
if you can be,
if you could be in your eighties and by the way,
it is theoretically possible to be in your eighties
and still put out two watts per kilo.
There are examples of people who do this.
I think Iñigo has coached one guy he's an 81 year old.
So he's a world champion at Masters 81.
He's about 2.9 or three watts per kilo.
Wow.
Can you imagine that?
Mm, we had a guy in here recently,
Mike Fremont, he's a hundred
and he owns all these world records at half
marathon and marathon distance running,
when he was like 90 and 91.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
That he's able to do that.
Talk a little bit about the importance of polarity training.
You talked about the different energy systems
in the context of longevity.
So this idea of Z2 and Z5
'cause what I see and I'm sure you see this all the time
is people who spend the vast majority
of their training time
in that gray zone.
They're not going slow enough to develop their aerobic
capacity, their mitochondrial efficiency and density,
and they're not going hard enough to really reap
the benefits of strength, power, etcetera.
Yeah, the no man's land, the garbage training.
It's an important zone, by the way, depending on your sport.
Like when I was time trialing,
we did spend a lot of time at three, four crossover,
'cause that's basically where you were racing
for a 20K time trial.
So you had to spend some time there,
but not too much time there, right?
I would say 80%,
I was probably only spending 70%,
I think in retrospect I should have been spending
a little bit more time there.
And at your peak, what was your zone two threshold watts?
2 75.
That's pretty good.
At 75 kilos.
Yeah.
So it was okay.
And for context, for people
that are listening or watching,
like a Tour De France rider is probably
little above 300, somewhere in that range.
Yeah, but much lighter than me, right?
So he would be 320 watts zone two.
So I mean the best of the best would be, yeah, yeah.
But they'd be 65.
140 pounds.
Yeah, exactly.
So yeah, I was 275 watts for zone two
at 75 kilos at my best
but not a very high FTP, right?
So that was, my FTP was only 310.
As time trialer, though, that becomes important.
Yeah, I mean, for me,
because I was a Merckx time trialist,
which is such a silly little niche thing.
It really, the arbitrage on Merckx's time trialing
became your CDA.
It's coefficient drag funnels surface area,
that was my obsession.
That's why I was so obsessed with it.
It was like just figuring out like,
'cause it wasn't so much that my FTP
wasn't that high,
it's that I could hold that at an uncomfortable position.
'Cause in a time trial
you're in such an compromised position
from a vascular return standpoint,
that if I could hold 300 watts in a tuck
and really minimize my frontal
surface area and coefficient drag,
I could go fast enough.
You're such a geek.
I can't imagine.
Every single day I would come home
from Fiesta Island.
Yeah.
And model calculate based on barometric pressure.
Right.
Based on density, like what was my CDA today?
Like did I get down to 0.2, one?
How do you have time for anything else?
That's like a job.
There's a reason I don't do it anymore.
Yeah, right.
It was a huge commitment to be able to do that.
And you know, I made a joke about this once I was like,
it kind of occurred to me
like how little anybody in the world cared.
Like one day I was having dinner with my wife
and I was like, do you know what my PR is for 20K?
Just outta curiosity.
Yeah.
Rich, she was off by a factor of two,
like literally couldn't care less.
And I was like, that's cool, I get it like,
It's amazing how much I care about this dumb thing
that no human on the planet cares about, which is fine.
There are a lot of things to this day I care about.
I love precision shooting.
So it's like,
to be able to shoot a dinner plate a mile away
is such an important thing to me.
It serves no functional purpose on this planet.
Yeah and the F1 stuff.
Right.
Which is like,
we could talk about that later and that's a whole sidetrack,
but I think, because I'm an engineer,
I just think engineers like data
and I really viewed time trialing
as purely an engineering problem.
'Cause it's not,
if you think about other types of bike racing,
there's strategy involved, there's nuance,
there's complexity.
But time trialing is purely an engineering problem.
Right, the bike is the perfect instrument
to extract data from.
A watt is a watt is a watt.
Yep.
And basically it becomes this like,
perfect situation for self experimentation.
Yeah, so cool.
It's crazy.
Which is interesting, I know that you,
I saw that you posted you were gonna get
a GPS watch and you kind of put it out on Twitter,
which watch should I get?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you made it very clear
that you didn't want a heart rate strap.
And I was like, that's very antithetical
to your whole thing because wrist heart rate is terrible.
Exactly.
Would you not?
You'll love this story, right?
So the reason I didn't want chest strap
is because I only want it for rucking
and when you're rucking,
you got a 60 pound thing on your back
and it's uncomfortable to have a chest strap
when you've got so much weight 'cause you're stacking.
But there's nothing comfortable about it.
How much more uncomfortable are you gonna be?
Fair point.
To get that pristine data.
But it was also like, I didn't want one more dumb thing.
Right.
So what did I do?
I ended up buying four of these watches
and keep cycling through them only to realize
that wrist based heart rate sucks.
It's terrible.
It doesn't matter which brand you're wearing.
Sucks.
It's just the technology.
So I returned them all
and got the cheapest one money could buy,
the Coros Pace 2 for 200 bucks.
That's a good watch though.
It's fine.
And then I got,
I use on the bike, I use a WAHOO
arm band and that's so that's what I use now.
Right.
So now I exercise with the WAHOO arm band and this watch.
So I defaulted into what everybody told me
from the beginning.
Got it, alright.
Well we're starting to fray at the edges here,
but let's kind of put a pin on the zone two,
zone five thing in terms of what?
Well, I didn't answer your question actually.
Yeah, we're still in the.
Yeah, so I would say if you're,
if you're training for a specific sport,
you're gonna have to understand what zone you need to be in
and spend the appropriate time there.
But if you're talking about health,
I think you're talking 90% is zone 2,
90% to 95%,
5% to 10% is zone five.
That's about it.
So I do one VO2 Max workout a week, that's it.
Yeah.
And you're constantly pricking yourself
and figuring out where your zones are,
but for the person who's listening,
who might not have access to a lab
where they can go and actually do this properly.
The point of kerolactate device
is all you really need, right.
I use something called,
I think it's called the lactate plus.
So you can buy these things online.
They're not cheap.
The device is probably $200, $300
and the strips are probably two bucks a piece, so it's.
But how do you administer the protocol
when you're actually doing the thing?
Well, remember zone two, you're not dying, right?
But you still have to go through all the zones
to establish.
Yeah, so it's empirical.
The first few times I did it,
it took me a while to be like,
oh, I'm well below, I'm well below.
Whoops, I overshot.
Okay, back off.
So I would just have a table next to me, set up.
And the biggest challenge actually is that you have to have
soapy rags there 'cause lactate
doesn't wash off with alcohol.
So you'll contaminate the whole thing
if your hands aren't clean.
Nobody's gonna do this.
I know you do, but I mean hit the protocol
that I've typically done in a lab and maybe it's different
from yours is you get on a bike,
you warm up for a while at maybe a hundred watts.
And then you basically launch into this interval workout.
Yeah, yeah.
Every four minutes you increase the wattage,
like 10 Watts.
So we do longer intervals
because of the lag between lactate
and the plasma and in the interstitial.
So we'll do,
we'll do six to eight minute intervals and yeah,
we'll just have somebody,
when our patients go and do the testing,
it's a prick to the ear to get the lactate.
Right.
But here's the other thing.
So it's heart rate, power, lactate and perceived effort.
Right, so we try to triangulate on those.
So if I'm telling a patient to do this at home,
what I'm basically saying is here's where
I think you're going to be.
So the first thing I'm asking
is what's your resting lactate.
Tell me that.
So when you wake up and you haven't eaten anything,
what's your lactate.
If that's two,
then you're metabolically so unhealthy.
That's screwed.
Then we're not doing lactate testing in you.
We're gonna do it all off RPE, purely.
That's it.
But let's assume you tell me,
oh, my morning, lactate is one.
Great.
Okay, so then I'm gonna say,
do you know your actual resting heart, pardon me,
your actual max heart rate, not predicted,
but truly achieved.
So you tell me that,
then I figure out how fit you are just by a few questions.
The fitter you are typically the higher a percentage is.
So your zone two can be as high as 84%, 85% ,
of your max heart rate if you're really fit.
If you're not, it's probably closer to 75%.
So then I tell them, okay, your heart,
rate's probably going to be here.
And I don't even try to predict watts.
So then I say, okay, I want you give 'em the bike.
And I want you to ride in slow increments until heart rate
is about here and your RPE is such that you can talk,
but you don't want to.
RPE, rate of perceived.
Exertion.
Exertion, yeah.
So then I would just say,
just do that for 45 minutes
and then do a quick lactate check.
And if they do that and it's 1.6, I say, great,
the next, in two days or the next day,
I want you to go out and do it.
And I want you to add five to 10 watts.
And if you come out and your 2.5 back off by 10 watts.
So we don't try to answer it all in one day,
but you can answer this question
over a period of a week.
Right.
And how is the adherence with your patients
when you tell them, okay,
your heart rate is not allowed to go over X
and they go out for a walk
and the minute there's the slightest incline,
or they want to put a little bit of kick
into anything they're doing, they're out of zone two.
And they're like, well, this is.
I try to keep them separate.
So I've actually found outdoor walking
and outdoor running to be very difficult for zone two.
So just like when I go rucking,
my heart rate is,
sometimes I'll hit max heart rate
if I'm on a steep enough hill.
So I just consider that a separate form of exercise.
Like a stationary bike?
Yeah, as uninteresting as it is.
I mean, I'm on a stationary bike
when I do it because I can control it.
And we try to have patients do it
on a treadmill stationary bike rowing machine,
super controlled, swimming is good too,
because you can really control your pace.
But outdoor cycling and outdoor walking,
running are hard.
Too many variables.
We don't wanna discourage people from doing those things,
but we just wanna acknowledge,
use those for maybe where you get your zone five.
Interesting.
Alright, our time's running short here
and I gotta let you go and get to the airport,
but I can't let you go without hearing
a little bit about this crazy TV show
that's coming out this fall "Limitless" that you did.
You did with Chris Hemsworth under the direction
of the great Darren Aronofsky.
I've seen the trailer.
I know it's coming out in this fall and I don't know how
much you can talk about it, but it looks absolutely epic.
And like quite the adventure.
It was a ton of fun.
Darren is a really close friend and you know,
Darren kind of pitched this idea to me probably in 2018.
He was like, I've got this idea.
I'm gonna pitch it to Nat Geo at the time.
Of course now it's Disney.
And he said, what do you think?
And I was like, I think it's a fantastic idea.
And he said like, who do you think should be the lead actor?
And we have a very close mutual friend in Hugh Jackman.
And I was like, what do you think about Hugh?
And he's like, that's perfect.
So he went and pitched Hugh to Nat Geo
and they loved the idea,
talked to Hugh, Hugh loved the idea.
And then it just, wasn't gonna work out.
Hugh had a bunch of other projects
that he really wanted to work on,
including "Music Man," and things like that.
Of course COVID messed everything up.
Yeah.
And then I don't know who suggested Chris,
whether it was Darren or the networks,
but then Chris became involved
and that in some ways changed
I think the focus of the program,
because I think.
He's quite a bit younger, obviously.
Right and Chris is like a superhero
and Hugh of course is, I mean,
you wanna talk about a guy with legendary fitness?
I don't know if you've seen "Music Man."
Yeah, he's unbelievable.
Yeah, yeah.
Not only like in his superhero fitness levels,
but also his ballet and like,
Yeah.
I mean his ability to move his body in space
and time is unreal.
Yeah, yeah, we were just in New York
to watch "Music Man,"
spend the weekend with him
and we had dinner after and I was like,
dude, I'm tired watching you.
And I don't know how you do that eight times a week.
Eight times a week he does this two and a half hour
show for a year.
What is he, 57 now or something like that?
Probably a bit younger than that.
Probably like maybe 53, 54.
But with Hugh, the idea we had
was kind of the way we opened our discussion,
which is you're no longer Wolverine,
what is it gonna take to be
the best version of you in your nineties?
I think with Chris,
the focus became a little more you're Thor.
Right.
Like what are the limits of that
and how do they jive with kind of longevity?
It was an amazing experience.
It took probably twice as long as anyone expected
because of COVID.
We started filming, we did a,
we did January and February a ton of work in 2020,
just before COVID hit in Australia
and in Norway and just by coincidence and by luck,
I suppose, those were the months I was heavily involved in.
Much of what came after, I became less involved in.
Yeah.
But there are six episodes
and I don't know what I can say about
any of them other than I think
there's some really good stuff in there.
I think my involvement is the least interesting
part of it is my personal take.
Like some of the other content that I've seen,
I find much more interesting
than the parts I was involved in.
And I think people will enjoy it a lot.
I first found out about it when Ross Edgley
was sharing some clips from.
Where are you guys in Norway?
Yeah.
Yeah, and swimming in the freezing water and all of that.
And Ross is like, I'm here with Darren and Chris
and I'm messaging, I'm friends with Ross.
And I was like, what are you guys doing?
How come I was not involved in this?
Or how come I wasn't invited?
I can't believe you guys are.
And he's like, ah, I can't really talk about it,
but it's cool.
So I've been joking with him about it
and I love Ross to death.
And I know that he worked really hard
in helping to train Chris for Thor
and got him in just insane shape.
But I'm curious on your perspective
on Ross and his kind of training protocol and philosophy,
given that he's,
attempting to do these ultramarathon swim adventures,
I'm always like confused by his approach.
I'm like, dude,
you should lose like 40 pounds of muscle
and trim down and you would have a better,
you'll lose some power,
but what you will gain in flexibility and efficiency
will completely outweigh that.
So what did Ross look like when he swam in college?
I think he was a water polo player in college.
I don't think he even swam competitively
and he's always been like compact and strong,
but there are videos of him like from years
and years and years ago,
like he has definitely progressed
as a kind of body buildingesque type specimen.
And he has his whole philosophy around it,
this mezzo phasing of the way that he trains.
But primarily he's in the gym doing tons of strength
training and the swimming doesn't come until much later.
But I just know when I put on upper body bulk,
I find it very difficult to swim
any distances without a lot of lactate buildup.
And when I was at my peak ultra conditioning where,
when I was training for Ultraman,
which is really a cycling race with a long run
at the end of it, I made the choice to sacrifice.
Ultra is 224 mile race?
Yeah, it's a three day double Ironman.
The first day, the first leg though is a kilometer swim.
Yeah, yeah.
But I was like, I'll just be like,
I will sacrifice my swim power to be able to have better
power to weight on the bike and be efficient on the run.
I kind of pushed that too far and got too skinny
where I had very little power per stroke,
but I was inexhaustible.
Like I just felt like I could swim forever
without getting tired.
And if he's swimming all the way around
great Britain and these other challenges
that he's planning on right now,
like doesn't that seem like a smarter way to go?
I mean, Ross is an amazing specimen.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
So far be it for me to judge what he's doing,
'cause it's working for him.
Yeah, yeah.
But I just thought like you,
as somebody who's interested in this kind of stuff,
whether you had a perspective?
No, not really.
One of the most interesting things that Ross and I got
really fixated on and what was,
and I don't know if I could talk about it.
'Cause I don't know if he's announced publicly
this kind of swim he has an aspiration to do.
I know about it.
I don't think that he's announced it publicly.
Yeah, so.
What we talked about that interested him was the sleep
cycling of it.
So a friend of mine, a cyclist named Mike,
well runner ultra runner,
ultra cyclist named Mike Travino lives in San Diego.
First year, he did RAM.
He was second.
He almost won RAM on his first attempt.
He got really into sort of timing sleep.
'Cause obviously with RAM for people listening,
it's this race across America,
it's a cycling race where basically it's just who can ride
their bike across America the quickest.
It's going on right now.
Yeah.
These guys are doing this in like eight days.
So you can imagine they're not sleeping
a whole heck of a lot.
And he was talking about how,
they're now able to sort of try to wake people up
at the right phase of sleep based on
rapid eye movement.
And so Ross was pretty interested in that,
which was if he was about to embark
on a really long swim,
we're talking things that would take weeks
and probably months,
could he really optimize his sleep
'cause what he didn't wanna do is sort of sleep eight hours,
swim, it's gotta be micros sleeps in there,
which again, I can't speak to how healthy
or unhealthy that is.
It just doesn't strike me as a great, longevity play.
But in the spirit of sort of pushing
the extreme limits of what a human can do,
that would be very interesting
other than just sort of random,
like when we used to do sleep sort of swim relays,
which we did a lot of these.
You'd sort of sleep three
and a half hours between your legs.
And it was just within three days, you're dead.
Right.
I feel like we're at the very beginning
of understanding what's going on with that.
And it does seem to be very personalized.
I know in the ultra running world,
like some people they can do these 15 minute little naps
and they seem to function at a pretty high output
and other people just can't manage it.
I have such respect for that.
There's a part of me that certainly always will miss
that type of pushing.
You're done.
Yeah, I'm done.
And I don't.
I'm really looking forward to kinda spending
the rest of my life trying to figure out
how to be a healthy, productive kick ass 90 year old.
Yeah, excellent.
Well, I think that's a good place to end it for today.
I could literally talk to you for six hours
about a zillion different subjects.
So I really appreciate you indulging me
and I hope you'll come back and talk to me again.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you for having me, right?
Yeah, thanks man.
So everybody check out Peter's stuff,
The Drive podcast.
I never miss an episode.
I think it's fantastic.
It's a great public service
that you're giving and I commend you for it.
And I just appreciate,
your openness to look at conventional wisdom
from a different point of view,
but a very objective grounded science based perspective.
And I've just gotten a lot of value
out of what you're doing.
So thank you for that.
I know you're working on a book that will be coming out
at some indeterminate time.
Sounds like February.
Teasing it a little bit.
Yeah.
So that's exciting.
Anything else you wanna mention or.
No, about the tour and the book
when it finally does make its way out here.
I can't wait to come back and chat about it.
Yeah, thanks man.
Well.
Seat's open for you.
Thank you so much.
Alright, cheers.
Thanks.
(upbeat music)